all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibontis and ty guy travis
thursday evening campfire what is going
on gentlemen how we doing e what's up
how start with you um yeah just trying
to basically figure out what's going to
be taking up my time in the next couple
of days we've got couple games and we
might talk about
you know what we're looking in after we
get into at least the main topics of the
show for destiny but i do want to kind
of cover
everything that happened outside of
destiny but i want to kind of save that
for the end more because there's stuff
i'm hyped for for obvious reasons there
was a trailer this morning that i got up
early for and everything else so uh kind
of of course excited for the minute
trailer perhaps
15 16 minutes yeah however long that was
exact
yeah
we will talk about that towards the end
kind of cover a little miscellaneous
topics um but yeah just kind of got a
couple games kind of pulling at me i
want to see which one i want to get into
both of them have some length to them so
i'm trying to decide which one to start
first uh travis what about you man
dressed as always trying to keep up with
the review world yeah i'm on that i'm on
that grind finished my review of
writer's republic which was a lot of
time and now i'm previewing a different
game for
ign so it'll be
another busy week and then and then
tonight i guess uh forza horizon is
coming out for people who have early
access so i'm going to be hopping on
that hard because the uh reviews that
came out this morning are yeah
yeah
that's one of the ones i'm i'm debating
on for sure it ign gave it a 10. yes
yeah there are not many masterpieces
what the hell would you have death lupus
masterpiece four's as a master is there
another masterpiece this year i feel
like there was one other
you're right there might be i can't
remember i feel like was it was open
death toll was rated high but i don't
know if
yeah i think open critical got um
the highest rated game of the year so
far so far for horizon five yeah i was
surprised how many obviously this is
like not not a reason but there's like a
lot of smaller outlets they gave it like
80s and 85s i was kind of yeah i was
kind of surprised by that yeah very
doing very well we got obviously having
a review up right now
on iop with attic shout out to him and
he had a great perspective because he's
like the the racing haters review
i'm just like okay you know i got
anything but yeah so you've been uh
getting in the grind traffic just
reviews and just
yeah yeah just grinding it out dude it's
gonna be a really busy
november so uh this is usually like the
busiest month of the year but it maybe
it's not as bad this year i mean until
yeah the destiny 30th anniversary and
the uh the halo infinite earlier
so there's a little bit of like a
lighter
thing now how about you cog what are you
been up to yeah man it's been non-stop
brother it's been non-stop between like
you said the review season and and
podcasting and and
it has been non-stop the only good thing
is i've been able to take my destiny
vacation still i'm still on it i'm still
on it
it feels good to be free for a little
bit i ain't gonna lie like i know i'm
coming back but it's just it's been
about two weeks now and um you haven't
logged on at all in two weeks haven't
haven't long done i have the last time i
logged on
was when you guys told me the nerf for
the because i was about to start
festival a loss then you said no
and i was like nah nah nah
yeah then i was like
uh just really see them yet
so close to the end
that's what got me so
close to the end and the pro the reason
why it's taking me longer because i have
like ocd with all like the different
tasks and the quests that i gotta like
save people randomly other do all the
detective work but um yeah i love that
game people are mad at me because i'm
like i've completely isolated myself
when i'm on gaming and i'm like don't
talk to me like i'm playing that's a
discord lazy like leave me alone like i
don't want to touch it like i'm becoming
very socially dysfunctional like it's
hilarious but yeah i love that
uh that i'm i'm nowhere near the end but
uh i'm working my way through it and i
so i don't know if i told you guys this
but i pride myself on uh playing all the
game completing all the games that get
nominated at the game awards yeah so
like i'm i'm on my like game
like your game of the year stuff for no
game awards like if it gets it gets
dominated i beat it like that's that's
what i like
the game of the year or like
most numbers
so that's like my uh i pride myself on
that so there's like a few obviously not
all the nominations have been announced
so i'm trying to uh
kind of like preempt it like there's
some i know are gonna have some sort of
nomination so i'm trying to get those
done but i'm on my final sprint i have
like six or seven games that i need to
be in november if i want to stick up to
the what's left i'm curious i want to
know what's on this list what's left
yeah so uh i'm not finished with death
store i assume that's going to get
nominated for it's not too long yeah um
psychonauts two and again that one's not
super long but i think that one will
probably get nominated for at least art
direction or something yeah it'll get
done
i'm like halfway through uh far cry
uh six which oh my god maybe that'll be
nominated for something but i i
definitely want to finish that one
i guess i haven't heard anything that
would make me think it's gonna get
nominated for anything substantial
it's more that like you just expect to
see those games um nominated and then
pretty much everything from the first
half of the year i've gone through i
think there might be one or two that i'm
still behind on i beat guardians of the
galaxy which i think we talked about
last week i still got to play very
awesome i mean i beat that game in one
day dude yeah i just like
devoured that game so that's on my list
that's next like yeah you guys should
play that that will definitely be
getting nominated for something i don't
know why i gotta get that
[Music]
trying to think of what other ones are
but yeah that that's uh i've i've got
i've got a lot of work to do in november
all my free time is gonna be catching up
that's hardcore respect i never do that
that's the most we do it just like vote
what we think are gonna win in each
category on iop and stuff but to play
every game nominated
not even like hey i want like four or
five hours in this one it's like no i
gotta roll credits on everything
you know what's funny is that i did it
because um i was at a different outlet
before ign and they used to do uh
voting and i would always get so
frustrated with the game of your voting
because you have people voting who
haven't played all the games yeah and
like you're like voting all these
categories and people just vote for like
the one game that they played or their
impressions right what another game was
i just got so frustrated by that i was
just like you know what i'm gonna like
double down and i'm just gonna next year
i'm gonna play every single game so
nobody can say that about me and i've
just been doing it since and i think i
started that like 2012 oh that's good
i gotta give it up to you now that that
right there yeah cause it's true i'm
guilty of it too like this you look at
the list like damn i didn't play that
but objectively how can you really give
an opinion on the game of the year or
the game or whatever character if you
literally didn't play that now you know
when i got exposed with that hades
saw oh oh obviously he's like fantastic
because at the time when it came out i
think it was switch only at the time
yeah that's switching pc first yeah we
switch your pc first so
i was just i didn't know about it he was
i'm telling you guys you guys are voting
all these categories and literally you
play hades you're frauds and he was on
the hades train so i was like look i
believe you but i just didn't play it so
i don't know
but he's right he's right that's one of
those two um i will give like you know
everybody has the game of giving to your
discussions and it's like i'm sure the
war rooms are interesting on some of
that type of stuff and
it's one of the podcasts i don't always
listen to giant bomb but they actually
do their full deliberation over the
course of like five days over every
topic they have everybody in like one
sweaty conference room
and i mean it probably is it's like you
know that many people in one room is
just gonna be a little bit but they
actually talk through everything
and they kind of do work stuff out and
as travis said it's like not everybody
is going to either be interested in
everything or have a chance to play
everything depending on obligations many
other things so it's like if you can
that's amazing but
again even within their realm there may
be like you know best story or best
style or whatever their categories are
it's like not everybody's gonna you're
not gonna play something that's on every
list
and yeah they kind of go through and
they talk about it and you know
somebody's gonna like make a case for
something and somebody and it's
hilarious sometimes like some people
make a case like so hard and be like
i was trying to put my game up for
number one but your case is like so
convincing like
you know it's like that makes them kind
of bump their own down just to give it
one credit so it's like there are a lot
of ways to handle that it's like props
we're trying to play everything which is
impossible for most people
but it's like it is one of those that's
what game of the year is always so hard
like these are my opinionated gamer
games of the year it's like for me right
now there's a few that are really high
on that list like
grimes
grime was like not top not game game of
the year i'm saying just like top ones
that are remembering rhyme for me was
like a standout indie like that was one
of my better indies like i played that
and then i played death's door and i
think grant grime made me like
appreciate death store less
because i got done playing yes wow cause
grime is a 2d souls game made by like
five or six people but i mean like
death's door is an isometric souls
like it is an action legend of zelda
okay fine like okay then it's a 2d like
what's the
salt and sanctuary legends like salt and
sanctuary is probably a good restaurant
yeah that's a good reference yeah that's
for grime um but they are like i mean
zelda's sure to a point but it's like
i find action either way but it's like i
played one hardcore action dodging
progression type game and then i went
and played another one like right next
to it and like grime was so unique and
like the style and like the world and
this weird story that it went through
was
just absolutely bizarre but kind of
crazy at the same time like i'm trying
to figure out what my character's
actually doing you get to this end
sequence and then like some of the boss
fates just absolutely sat me down like
no no you can try that again
uh and then i went through and played
death's door and it wasn't nearly as
much of a challenge like first boss i
got to didn't check me it was just like
it wasn't quite the challenge and while
it was very cool and like cool themes
after playing one that was done
i went from one that was almost done by
smaller people and almost to me like
kind of did it better in some ways not
all but some to that one it's like i
always see paris for example like death
stories like his game of the year and i
was like i get it that it was good but
for me in reference like
it does yeah you just came from grime no
i know where you're coming from i have
situations like that with certain games
a specific genres and it's like
yeah this is the better
game but it may be like obscure
it's like the way you're feeling about
that the only cross reference i have is
like because i'm such a turn-based guy
with
um i'm playing phoenix protocol now that
it's on gamepad and i'm like i mean bro
i'm an xcom guy i'm like
um phoenix protocol the one that um
julian gallup the original xcom creator
made from xcom ufo defense from back in
the playstation days when it launched
and he's now doing his own game
and man like i'm like yo this kind of
superior x cardboard likes really i'm
like that's crazy i'm sick and i got
instead i'm a person that has x-com
god here like that is my favorite dance
ableton my boss is
bringing him through bring him through
breakdown i am turn-based god like the
way i mean the way he likes um souls is
how i get with turn-based games any term
basically i gotta at least find out
what's going on i'm talking about like a
grid based game or like the like even
turn-based rpgs like the yeah even
turn-based rpgs like turn on that's why
you like yakuza like a dragon huh
once they told me it was termed i was
like oh that's the one
i'm all in i'm all oh that that was like
i know midnight suns is like you know if
they can do it right as the perfect
combination oh my god that'll be so good
it got delayed we actually did see it
got delayed but honestly as you said i
saw your tweet quick like you were the
first one i saw on it and i looked
looked and read and i was like you're
like just fine just doing it right yeah
just do it right that's right that's
kind of where we're out on everything so
it's like
so what else have you guys played like
just kind of go around and pick like one
game so this is like grime for me
returnal man
that for me was
just a hell a hell of a journey for me i
really thoroughly enjoyed what it did
the challenge like the environments and
like how they combined like
the time loop
bullet hell
uh roguelike just the combination of
genres and it's like you took you saw
how smart go from like resogun there's
one in between which i didn't play and i
can't remember the name of like that
kind of their isometric one which looked
more like hades kind of
uh and then they did like this 3d just
i'm like damn
so like return was a big one for me this
year what about you guys what are some
big games for you this year
another one on my list i just haven't
got there yet
that one is so good i think it like if
we're talking game of the year like
what's going to take home the big prize
i think uh playstation sort of bumps
itself off with like death loop sort of
for me like returnal was like the best
game of the year when it came out and
then death loop sort of knocked it off i
was like all right so yeah
so what about death loop did it for you
i'm curious because i sat there i'm
curious well it's like the main reason
like i started listening to no offense
the last and i was starting to listen to
their death loop discussion and you had
dustin rick hogue was on there and i
already knew he wasn't a fan by some of
those
and then maddie and like none of them
were talking high about it and i'm like
i don't even want to listen to it i
turned it off
didn't even want to listen to the issue
i
didn't get into it that far because i
was like
i know maddie doesn't yeah okay i was
like
i think he said he was like he's like a
big arcane guy right yeah he's like
arcane is his heart so for him
not that he doesn't think it's terrible
he like he likes it he think it's a good
game he's just that his thing is when it
comes to other
arcane games and the pantheon
this is like don't say the worst arcane
game but definitely in the middle to low
tech compared to the other experiences
so his whole thing is he i think he just
feels that the uh
freedom of of choice and the way the
level design is structured that like you
really
it's limiting in comparison to past
arcane games that's what it is so the
best example i could give i don't know
if you guys are fallout guys but you
know a lot of people love fallout 3
right and they feel it's true rpg right
but when four came out they felt it was
dumbed down they felt there were certain
aspects that were taken away so if
you're new to fallout 4 fallout right
you play fallout 4 you're like yo this
is amazing right so his thing is just
that from where he came from and their
history he sees some regression on a
certain thing so he's not as like oh
this is a perfect game the way ever
other people he's good he said it's good
but he doesn't feel it's like a 910 but
i know he wasn't trying to hit it
because i know he loves that game he
thought he did
no but i was like and i can get that and
i haven't honestly it's my first arcane
game so point of reference and
perspective is going to be my friend
yeah
like oh right
like i haven't ever played them so for
me it's
the like i was playing it on stream and
anybody can ask that like when i was
playing i was having like
i didn't expect because i wasn't
entirely sure going in i'm like i don't
know if i'm gonna like the whole time
loop thing can't tell on the style
i had a blast every time i booted that
game up ask anybody in chat and it was
just like it was so much
fun the banter between the two main
people every time you get to like a new
loop like they're giving you each other
like that writing alone i was like out
the gate i'm like every time it was like
pure legit just like great i like
writing and voice acting between those
two the entire time and then you start
figuring out more about this and to me
what like
if you guys have ever gone to an escape
room like in person if you've ever done
one it was a combination of an escape
room and a time loop because you have
this like four by four grid time of day
and which place you want to go to and
you're trying to figure out how you can
go through and do
like okay how do i move this person and
you're trying to figure out all the
chess moves to finally get to the end
but also like you also have the
progression where you're going through
and you're getting the um
what the hell are the damn slab upgrades
that you can get and then i'm like oh
cool i got this one it's like well yeah
you can upgrade i'm like i'm sorry
excuse me so i can just literally go
back in a loop to that dude again and i
can have fun it's like then you find a
silenced pistol where i'm just like
picking off heads and just something
about it every time it's like it was
not too punishing and that some people
said the ai wasn't that smart and i'm
like well they are kind of dumb grunts
they're meant to be in my understanding
of like but i was like and then some of
them were a little more but it was like
overall it wasn't so much about that it
was the like journey to like thread this
puzzle together and then finally when
you get to the end and it was honestly
like nice enough because if you did step
away and you jump back you don't have to
remember the code to this box here 6514
or something like that it tells you like
there were some nice quality of life
things i thought paired with just a fun
sandbox and i had a blast like i just
had an absolute blast in it to me so i
was like
everybody people agree with you don't
get me wrong like he represents he knows
he's in the minority because for a lot
of people this is gonna be their first
arcane experience and they're gonna
absolutely love it he still says it's a
great game like he's not you know again
this is just this is what i call bougie
game snob stuff right where it's like
you know that company it's like if
bungie comes out when bungie comes out
with mad or whatever we we're gonna get
to compare halo destiny and we as knobs
are gonna know what's the thing right
but it's still great it's just a
pantheon of greatness where does it fall
well it doesn't have the supers or
whatever it's like it's going back to
the halo like it's just gone yeah
yeah that's all it is that'll be that'll
be a fun discussion whenever that date
comes
yeah for me i always think game of the
year should be the game that like
brought the industry forward the most
like did something that like changed the
landscape and so i've talked about on
this show a bunch of times since i
started to get to know you since last
year
uh that my game of the year last year
was half-life alex because if you play
the game there's like nothing else like
it
and i'm a little late oh boy did i talk
to you guys about that a lot uh yeah oh
boy i'm cosine now that i'm vr owner uh
quest 2. oh have you played it
whoa
yeah yeah i started i was like okay
yeah yeah yeah i'm very impressed very
impressed we'll talk definitely more
about it but continue
yeah i was going to say this this year i
feel like um there's not like an obvious
one for me like one that like i just am
like you know there's like a lot of
games that do do a lot of things right
like eternal but
i kind of think hades is still the best
like roguelike game right like it it
it's it's still to me got that formula
like absolutely perfect um and i feel
that way about lots of games that came
out this year that like they're
like death loop is an amazing game it's
maybe up there for my game of the year
i'm not sure yet but it doesn't it it's
to me pray is still their their best uh
their best game okay
what do you have a contention like
what's your contention for the year so
far what's your what's battling for the
top spot for you right as of right now i
know this could change yeah that's yeah
and that's the thing is part of me
thinks that my favorite game of this
year hasn't come out
i think it yet is like well yeah hey but
halo is not going to be included in like
the official game of the year because
really the cutoff is november but um
like probably halo like that that game
is one that i played a ton this year and
then uh the other one would be like
forza forza comes out like later tonight
in early access and i could see that
easily being one of my favorite games of
course it will never get nominated
i love i love
i tried to lose
today
here i can even look in my notifications
or whatever it's not that far about how
it'll never get nominated i think aims
and i were talking about that yeah
basically just said this year i formally
reviewed little nightmares resident evil
village that's another one i played uh
psychonauts 2 death loop paternal uh
i've played death store it takes two oh
dude i forgot it takes two i played that
with my wife
who you gonna play with i don't know
play it was like playing with a couple
one jump in
you got to play it with somebody who
hasn't played it yeah you have to play
with something you have to play with
yeah you can't play with like
ratchet and clank i haven't touched
but because i'm waiting on my monitor so
that's another one he said after using
forza horizon 5 it isn't in game of the
year nomination it's a big mistake and i
can't wait to get my hands on it i said
it sounds like it very much deserves me
to be in contention for the game of the
year not everyone vibes on racing games
but quality products speak to themselves
is basically what i said
and
it is one of those that it's true like
racing games i know aren't for everybody
not everybody's a car guy like honestly
i know not everybody on the podcast is
probably into cars as much as i've been
it's like some are we had a senate nomad
on here and he started talking cars i'm
like oh here we go like yeah just like a
podcast and i lit up on that one yeah
it's like because i followed cars i had
a lamborghini countach poster on my wall
forever like
oh
yeah so it's like i've been into cars
for so long so when you get like the
racing game that nails it like in forza
3 motorsport 3 i think is the one that
really turned me um for forza yeah but
it was like when they nail it they are
special games when they do it right but
again like need for speed underground
too was like one of my favorite need for
speeds like but it's never in that
discussion it's just like racing never
quite makes it there it's like racing
sports they're just kind of like yeah
you can tell they don't like it when
they give their own category for the
games nobody cares about they're like
it's racing sports just like throw them
all
together yeah like
i remember i think i think my game of
the year the year forza horizon 4 came
out or maybe it was three the australia
one uh
that year that was like my game of the
year and it was nominated by no one it
was like like no one gave it a a
nomination i was so confused and then i
realized like there's some there's some
serious bias
there's there's racing and it's let's be
honest there's multiplayer game bias too
you know i mean like you know i you know
you know like i've been hard body on
destiny with music and i'm like yo it
never gets a domination type situation
like it was there's always like the god
of wars and you know the single player
and stuff yeah burn out paradise like
burnout whichever burnout paradise i
think is one of the best like how many
if you played that game you had way too
much fun and that's one of those to
where it's like
what is one i mean the crash mode people
have tried to even gone back and
reinvent like there are certain things
that as you said kind of transform
places and the forza horizon 5 does this
magical thing is actually listen to
scallops review about it and stuff and
even he's not like as much a racing he
wants like the car pg i like what he
called that um how do you get the
progression yeah it's like it works
because like that was needed for speed
underground you get your clunker you
slap a crappy wing on the back you get a
little wheels you start winning a couple
races and that's kind of description he
said horizon's not quite that style but
he's like even for him wanting that he's
like it's just literally fun everywhere
you go and it's like and that's one of
those that's hard to compete so it's
like
not everybody's gonna like a racing game
but man it's like if you like cars and
again that's not everybody's interest
but it's like for what it's doing it
definitely hopefully gets and it's a 10
for ign so hopefully like yeah like
that's got to be in the discussion now
central also yeah i think uh
like playground games in my opinion is
probably like in the top three best
developers right now like like like just
period they've never made a bad game our
games are always getting better i have a
theory that they will not be recognized
for their talent until they come out
until fable comes
the rpg they get fable but nobody gets
the fact that they're making incredible
rpgs already and the reason that they're
the perfect developer for fable one
because they're british company you
gotta keep in britain and then two
because they have already been mastering
the rpg genre it's just people don't
care because it's a car game and it got
me sad exactly it's funny because as a
person who is a race i say i'm racing it
i've cooled off on the simulation aspect
like the motor sport right
right so what happens is when
motorsports and stuff come out i don't
want to
get the drivetrain and the cam [ __ ] like
i'm not any of that right just throw me
in there i don't want to tweak nothing
so when horizon came out and it was not
um turn 10 it was these guys i was like
okay
and i fell in love and i was like you
know what i knew there was the goat
when they had to rewind feature
i said this is for me i'm trash let's do
it again motorsport had the rewind
feature motorsports yeah
true but it's just that the way the
horizon does it and everything is a feel
good it's a festival it's dude
everything you do it's like yeah
yeah spin go on adventure find these
cars and i was just like yo horizon for
me and play with your friends at an open
world car game like i knew i knew i was
like this this is the series for me but
i agree with you driving like they're
not going to get they're not going to
get their flowers sadly until fable
comes out and it's a shame people are
going to be like where did this like
fantastic rpg company come from and
we're people's horizon players will be
like bro
yeah look at metacritic all their games
are keep increasing in their uh
metacritic rating and the the highest
rated games what xbox's most underrated
studios we have to give it to them and i
love obsidian ninja's theory all those
guys but
i would be remiss not to mention
playground it's it's the greatness is
too much at this point we have to you
know bend in the end somewhere but you
cough what's on your list as we've said
a couple where where you're
what's a game for the top for you since
we fell down this rabbit hole and people
were like where's the destiny talk we'll
get there don't worry not a lot going on
so we're back on
trials episode 6 of destination we
didn't have a uh major release this year
that also true um yeah for me currently
right now
i've been with traff but i don't think
my game of the year has come out i've
played it yet and um that's why i still
have to play um guardians and a couple
others i like returning but it left a
bad taste with me because of i was a
victim of the crash thing
so i lost all my data and i was just
like no i'm not going back to you sorry
like i'm not i'm not risking that now i
should try it again my probably would
not have patch and all that stuff yeah
this package that's the save state thing
is now there too
yeah i know but i'm talking about the
time that just got there like when this
thing came out it was none of that so
for right now i've got in my head
surprisingly it was it's psychonauts
surprising
it's something else
so
goofy and out there but the the way it
deals with mental health in such a
comedic but cool way and understanding
way um yeah man like i was really
impressed so
that right now that's leading but again
i still got to play his takes too which
comes out this week on game pass that
was still good man that was good
yeah people rave about that right and
now everyone's telling me listen threw
me over was hulk
when he said guardians of the galaxy and
i'm saying him on twitter yeah you
i said cause we i tease hogue all the
time i'm like you're the most fussiest
marvel dc comic book guy i know like he
hates everything right
i have a friend like that yeah yeah like
he's so particular that he will just
like destroy your game because like the
littlest things it might be right so
when i see a hog
gushing about something
i'm like oh
and so all my friends are saying
guardians of the galaxy so yeah i doubt
i got that shot to send us to my my
share partner so we will uh
get that he got that download i said bro
bro you're up
so uh yeah i'm about to try that
johnny's a galaxy's definitely on my
list for game of the year unexpectedly i
was not expecting that at all it's very
good
yeah man what's going on dj what's up he
said what's charles like this week
you're talking about right
get into it yeah i'm like exhausted
already
well yeah to say the least it's like um
we talk about destiny a lot but guys we
definitely talk about other things
plenty
so
maybe offline as opposed to during the
podcast so if you guys do enjoy
discussion like this if it's something
you'd like to see tacked on at the end
you know maybe it's like just a
miscellaneous games discussion just
because you know we always have other
stuff that's going on
um me it's like
i gotta say it now i got to watch 15
minutes of elderly game plan i just lost
my mind this morning i i'm like
there's crafting there's an open world
horse
there's still souls combat you've got
multiple avenues
there's a but it's like the perfect
souls map because it's just stylized old
school but you can actually put markers
on it so you got the open world and then
the beacons and then you have like one
of the six major castle situations god
knows how big those are going to be
multiple entrances to go in as well i'm
like is there anything else that you can
put in this game and i probably haven't
even seen it yet but i'm like i
i'm so mad the timing of that game i
literally come like
january was going to be so perfect
because i was because this game needs
time because i'm like you're going to
explore the open world apparently you're
going to have some crafting involved
you're going to be like roaming around
or do i want to tackle this group here
or wait to like tackle that chaos later
here's this thing which way do i go in
it will get delayed again
i would honestly at this point i want it
to be i really do like destiny
yeah i need to yeah one or two
somebody's gotta fall
and horizons right before it like you're
playing a game of chicken how do you
have horizon like
for destiny and then
elden ring in a week like in one week
how did
is no can nobody call and be like dude
like can you just move it like a month
well give me a little like
bro somebody's gotta blink these are two
these are major releases what elder
rings date is tentatively what in
february the week before which queen uh
three days before
three days after four days before and
three days after yeah horizon's four
days before it's the 18th then you have
the 22nd for witch queen and sifu and
then you have saints on the 25th with
elden ring so a week and there's five
five games
four of which are bigger no way
no way longer somebody saying saints
will definitely budge i feel like delay
dance has to get budged
but i was like horizon and then destiny
it's like eldon needs to
elden
i wanna i would love them both to move
but i'm like elden needs to move as it's
after because i can't make that one
oh
it's just
it looks so good and it's like
they're finally doing like they're
adding just a couple more things it's
like i already love souls games and even
they like i honestly can't even remember
if bloodborne had a jump i don't know if
it did
no and then i saw him do this little hop
and i'm like
now you can explore so much the jump
looks so like out of place and uh i i
think it was in um
exactly
started kind of the jump but the
grappling hook was big for it because
that was like crazy traversal but the
levels were still a bit more linear like
you could have some elevation to move
around in like the areas of fighting but
like this one it's like oh i'm just
going to hop across this ledge and go
around a completely different area
now i was like and just like what does
it do a little baby jump changes the
whole damn game much less the horse that
can
vault up a cliffside
no like i watched that this morning got
up streamed it with like you know a few
people that were awake at that point i'm
just like ah
yeah and i just finished alan wake
remastered today too
nice would you like nice how'd you like
yeah
no it was like it was i mean it's 13
years ago
it's like a good game but it has an h1
unfortunately yeah it's like it's it's
the age yeah because it's change yeah i
mean it's game mechanics of which you
like oh i just had i was fully stocked
up with all the different weapons and
all the ammo i go on a helicopter and
then i jump out and now i'm empty again
i'm like what the hell like that's one
example of
so it's like it's one of those yeah um
the ending is one of those where i
literally must have to go look up i'm
like i'm not entirely sure what exactly
happened in the end because you have to
play the dlc yeah and then apparently
there yeah there are two dlcs that are
on there as well so i could check those
out but
i was like it was it was a you know
decent little experience and stuff i
don't know what i would rate it but it's
it's a 13 year old game it looks i had
some weird graphical glitches though
like
messed up like for dlss i had to have it
off dlss because
anytime i would like move like certain
like vertices and stuff would like
flicker as i turned them like
then so in the beginning of the game i
had it on i'm like am i just like in a
dream is everything flickering because
i'm like no i thought it was that and
then i turned it off and it's not there
i'm like son of a okay
scratch that whole idea
so like that's whole thing but later on
there was a point where like the entire
lower portion of a canyon or an entire
river was solid white like so white and
then if i
i loaded in after i mentioned that
helicopter i jumped off it's like okay
you got to go over here if i turn the
screen almost every texture was
blindingly white
like busted white like whatever happened
yeah i think so yeah they don't make
they don't make games for pc very well
no i think it was epic um oh it's epic
game store okay but either way it was
just like whatever happened to the
remastered pc port and my computer which
i don't know
like whatever i i was literally running
it at like 50 rendered resolution like
not up down i was playing at like 720p
yikes
because if i bumped it up to even 100
the whole screen was blinding white for
whatever section i was at i got to it
i'm like i can't move because i would be
like i can face right here
and i would be okay and i would turn
white and i'm like oh god
like
seriously
oh so i was so confused with what was
going on yeah blinded by the light
anybody like ask anybody who was there
this morning it was just it was too much
so that was
that and then the ending on top of that
and i'm like it's it's just fine
for the ending but yeah it was very cool
when it came out trust me i mean i can
see how it was because like what it did
was actually not bad i could also see
how some people
would really get tired of the narration
that was one of the big critiques when
uh the reviews came out for that game as
they were like why does this guy never
shut up and i was like yeah i mean he's
a writer he's like he is a writer but
it's like oh look i have to find
somewhere to hit the switch i'm like no
kidding dude that's the whole point of
me being in this room but you don't have
to like verbally tell me that first you
do it where he's like reading more yeah
yeah they got they got the money on that
voice actor
even if you didn't like the game or even
if you have no interest in it you should
go and watch the prequel uh
minisodes they did like webisodes for
the show called bright falls and it is
unironically like some of the best like
short it's you know kind of like indie
it feels like an indie movie it's like
indie movie uh horror it's live action
it's a prequel to alan wake and it's
very good
here yeah but i've heard that could
connect to control and there might be a
feature there later so it's like it's
one of those
controls see i've heard that
and i haven't played control again
because i'm waiting to kind of walk play
some things on my fancy monitor if it
ever gets out of the port of la which i
see
what
uh but yeah that's
yeah it was it was an interesting i
literally beat it in three nights so
like i looked up and they're like oh
yeah like 11 hours i'm like really and
then like
14 hours of your try and i didn't find
every thermos i'm like i don't care
about those it's fine
but on the other side i was like how
long did it take me like
seven eight maybe it was not like even
the 11 like because i looked up like how
long to beat and it was just not even
there so
it was yeah
interesting and i was like if i can put
myself 13 years ago had some cool
moments to it i can tell you like birds
flying in like from like i'm over here
and then it pans out and there's birds
flying at you from like you're five
o'clock i can like whip around with my
mouse and like flash a light on them i
could imagine controllers like ah
like trying to move
like i could imagine on console that
game had and apparently if you do
nightmare mode
you you die in one you only have one
life
nightmare mode's crazy and i was like
nope no way i would do that no honestly
because
oh hell no there the main reason is
because like i would be like oh that's
not good combat's not good you don't
have that level of control it's like
that would be awful things like if if
the if a game is challenging i'm all
down for that as long as the combat is
good if a game is challenging the combat
isn't good it's just frustrating it's
all hell it's like i'm dying and it
doesn't feel fair like it's so bad
that's like the difference if you get
any time in your crazy schedule try
grime actually
oh i'm sure it'll get nominated for
something that's on my list i already
bought it i just haven't played it yet
yeah
well we are about 38 minutes in here we
should probably talk about this game
called destiny we do what this is not a
destiny podcast no but what uh
not much happened this week we got iron
banner
that uh loaded in salad and went to the
tower it's really sad after a holiday
event though as we'll say the first time
you go in the tower and it's like
you know like the sweeper bot came
through was like
power wash the entire place nothing's
left over and you're like
damn this place is kind of uh ghost town
now all right um
yeah not even seasonal thanksgiving
stuff would be nice i don't know but i
was like there's nothing in there right
now so iron banner what are you doing
what are you doing to keep things spicy
with this relationship you have this
this uh toxic relationship you have with
this woman called destiny what are you
doing because we know what cog is doing
is seeing other women that's how he
keeps it spicy right i mean you can see
i'm seeing other women apparently as
well you're seeing other women too is
that is that your strat like what are
you doing to
uh like keep keep things alive with the
the destiny situation
how do you plan when you log on what are
you doing these days we know you're
logging on we see the zur videos yeah
see the videos grandmasters their weekly
videos actually did yeah because it was
uh devil's lair this week for the grand
master and i was like this can't be that
bad and i'm like plus 20 because i've
been just playing enough random stuff i
mean when trials is there i'll play a
little bit over the weekend which has
been a thing i still played this past
week and we'll talk about that in a
second
um but yeah devil's there i was just
kind of going in it took a little bit to
get to lunch and i was like you guys
want to do a grand master and got new
red and he had one other person and
put a couple attempts in had to adjust
the inventories and then sure enough we
got through the grand master granted it
was like 56 minutes
so it was like it wasn't a but it was
like it was the easiest grand master you
can probably do because all you gotta do
is sit in the right spot for any of the
fights just sit back and like pace
yourself because i mean every piece the
grandmaster
is
going to give you room to fight from
you're not stuck in a really crappy
situation you're not stuck in like
proving grounds arena where you have no
room to fight and you've got to live in
bubbles or something you can sit at
range and shoot stuff because it's a d1
strike and it was before they started
making everything circular arenas where
you run around with the chicken with
your head cut off so
devil's lair in and of itself is
actually not even bad at all for doing
grand master went through and did that
one got a couple pieces um and then a
little bit of iron banner just to kind
of test out the
the armor
uh the fire looks pretty good find the
right shader yeah like every chess piece
and then apparently like little accents
on a couple others for
um titan and hunter and warlock they're
little accidents on a couple of them but
what's up the chest is the big one about
to say is it one particular set like how
how we it's the current iron banner set
oh it's the card one so you got a graph
for the okay i got you guys yeah the
current iron banner set which i couldn't
tell you the name of off the top of my
head but is the current set the chest
iron runner iron maybe iron four runner
forerunner yep that's it iron runner
yeah uh for at least for us i don't know
if it's different names for you guys but
um yeah
so it's called for the titans yeah let
me see so yeah but yeah i mean they said
so apparently i keep seeing
differing ideas on this one i think when
iron banner is active the fire on your
chest will be active but when it's not
active it won't be
uh but the other thing about the iron
banner it does have that set bonus so if
you wear multiple pieces you get a
chance at prisms at the end of matches
uh and then you can also equip your
ghost where on precision kills you have
a chance to get prisms as well so if you
play if you grind out a decent amount of
iron banner like it's not gonna happen
every time some people my comments have
said not much has happened for them i
literally played like three matches one
i got a precision kill saw prism next
one i saw a prism drop just at the end
so if you're looking for prisms and you
can you know if you've grinded up the
set like if you've got that set or
you're missing a couple pieces start
throwing them on there and working on
that and don't forget about the ghost
especially if using things like hand
cannons pulse rifles snipers anything
that's gonna get that precision kill
more frequently
no reason not to it's just kind of a way
to
um
get a little extra because i know it's
like sometimes people don't have the
best way to get currencies correct
some people are swimming in them but for
some people that might be the easiest
way to get them so i made a video about
it so no doubt
but i mean like this week when you log
in i'm kind of going
uh
that's i mean that's why but that's also
where we're at right now so it's your
time to work on
seals catalysts solo
i mean
it's kind of one of those points to
where it is that weird moment it's like
is there anything you're trying to work
on are you trying to solo a dungeon are
you trying to
you know find all the little things it
is that weird triumph hunting situation
right now probably more than anything or
working on
just stuff that you haven't typically
had time for and might be pulled other
directions
question when do we think
we get advancement on the narrative
when do we think that might happen
my guess is either
the week before the 30th anniversary so
like into this month which is probably
what 30th i guess if we can do calendar
things
yeah so 30th or
february 15th and i don't know which
i don't know that's my question is like
in theory what happens in the quote
epilogue of season of the lost if
they're gonna still call it that type of
thing
is going to be something that ties into
witch queen it doesn't tie into the 30th
anniversary i think that's kind of a
here's your cosmodrome pirate dungeon
gal horn quest here's a little fill-in
content that doesn't seem to probably
have any story stuff per se
so then if we get to that point
yeah because you're going to have the
donning you're going to have
what's the
end of the year
thingy
solstice of heroes is that the right
no that's the summer event
that's summer
isn't dawning like the new year kind of
thing dawning's like the christmas
coverage when they're out of the office
like they take their vacation and have
fun with that that's like only what i do
snowballs and stuff like that but yeah
like yeah so they'll run that for a few
weeks but there's going to be something
moments of trap that's the one i was
looking for thank you um moments of
triumph is going to be probably what
comes towards
right after that i would imagine so it's
either going to be between those two or
moments is going to run in the last two
weeks
so if it doesn't happen in
well basically on the 30th my guess is
it's gonna happen
two weeks before witch queen launches
you get people back into the story
yo i'll say he's a fool we still they'll
move the story if the community can make
20 million oh my god
i was sanity you were fool for that one
and you know what's sad
this might be the truth
i mean it's not the first time
outsanity you're not supposed to say
things on the podcast because apparently
they can listen so shh
that was hilarious that's that's where
we're at we've got festival's done
30th is coming 30th we'll get it's like
gallahorn quest dungeon solos don't know
if there's a difficulty who knows
as soon as they you know take their
holiday break that's when they'll kick
off the donning let it run for four
weeks
that'll take us into january then that
then the moments of triumph will
probably run straight up to the end of
the year and my guess if they do it
right is you finish the story before you
go into which queen
yeah so
it would be weird to me to finish the
epilogue and then wait three months to
go into witch queen yeah to me now
granted would it be i would have rather
had it like weeks ago at the like week
eight when the season was actually done
and then you can wait for the expansion
but at least you know what got you there
as opposed to uh chapter seven of eight
and pause
so no that's that's my guess is a week
or two before witch queen and sadly
nothing until then
how are you handling this whole
relationship right now obviously you've
been reviewing a lot of games you know
yeah i mean so like i'm i'm cog like i'm
always seeing other women like i would
say i probably like
that's sort of like my women are not
coming off on our podcast i would just
like to say right now to the ladies out
there we are we are playing other games
we do not see women as objects right now
we here at the last word support all
females and males and equality and
everything else that i have not said
already
we are supportive of every color and
every flag and every ribbon
please please stop please stop
slut-shaming me i'm just trying i'm just
out here i'm trying to
uh yeah
like
i guess my default my default is like
destiny is i have like staples that i
always will come back to and i'm always
sort of like playing while i play other
games and then on top of that i've got
the reviews and i've got games that i'm
just like getting through for my own uh
sort of um
you know just uh because i like to play
lots of different games um so that's
sort of not unusual for me what i'm what
i've actually been doing in destiny is
really weird for me which is i'm finally
catching up on the stuff that i don't
want to do and destiny so like i like i
told you guys last week i did strikes
and i did gambit and i got those um
ornaments from previous seasons i'm also
clearing out my quest log and i realized
last weekend
i still don't have the new exotics that
are in the master lost sectors i totally
forgot to do that this season so
i've been looking for when the arms are
available e i almost texted you to be
like e can you just let me know when the
arms are available because i kept
logging on and every day i happened to
log on the arms were just never the one
that that problem was dropping
i just had really i've had a really bad
luck lately but i i still don't have
there's a calendar
so you can plan it a little better you
have a calendar wow this goes he's
waiting i'm not going to claim it i was
like i thought about doing it and then
or fallout had one made so it's just a
spreadsheet that it's like i don't know
if he totally updates it or it's like
kind of community done but yeah i know
there's a link to a spreadsheet where
you can literally see like what is on
what day so it's easy to do nice okay i
like that um
but uh sort of
as you guys know my philosophy on
destiny is i never want to hate the game
and so i try not to do things that i
that i know are gonna make me hate it
like i really don't like to grinding
a ton of stuff
yeah lost sectors is a great way to to
make you hate the game uh
doing the uh the halloween event like
i only did the halloween event because
there was nothing else in the game to do
and i was sort of like whatever i can
take a couple hours and just like do
that but um
like i sort of saved my uh i don't i
didn't do all my grinding just front
loaded like a lot of people do where
they actually
tried to do everything this season right
away so now i've got things to do i can
log on a couple hours a week and you
know a couple times a couple times a
week
just for a few hours and uh get through
everything that way when we get to the
20th anniversary and when we get to
which queen i'm not going to hate myself
or hate destiny
because that's the one thing that i
really i've been bad at that in the past
like i remember when uh
forsaken came out i think i had played
way too much destiny because i was
already sick of destiny when forsaken
came out uh and and it i still loved
forsake him but i in back of my head i
was like dude i've been playing too much
destiny i'm gonna get off this game like
really bad so
my goal is to never do that again
because i like my relationship with
destiny when i'm like legitimately
enjoying it and i log on and i'm like oh
there's stuff to do i'm not just like
spinning my wheels and so
um unfortunately as you guys know the
comp situation has always been my that's
always been my fallback and it's in a
pretty bad place right now like there's
not a lot no point to do that playlist
at all yeah there really is no point to
do the competitive playlist and trials
is you know i've gotten everything i
need and now it's also not really a
competitive mode so uh i haven't really
uh gotten
played a lot more of that um so yeah i'm
sort of
catching up on other stuff that's how
i'm keeping it fresh
in the in the guardian bedroom have you
played
gambling
i have played gambit and it is awful it
is still really bad um the only one
no here's the thing is i should like
gambit it's like pve pvp i i say i'm a
pvp maine but that's just because i
actually like pvp as much as i like pve
and if you play destiny and you like pvp
equally to pve they call you a pvp man
right like uh because so many people
don't like pvp at all yeah uh so so that
that's kind of like how i i
got labeled the pvp main but um i should
like gambit my problem is that they just
let the mode stagnate way too much it
really sucks to play it in matchmade
teams just because there's so many
people are trying to complete optional
objectives and nobody knows how to dunk
the moats and nobody knows nobody's
communicating the invasion everybody's
like standing in front of the heavy ammo
for a full minute waiting for it to drop
so they can complete a bounty or they're
standing in front of the invasion gate
not helping at all because they want to
be the person to invade and it's just
like it's it's like weirdly political in
there i hop into a gambit match and i
feel like i've stepped into like a town
hall there's like these people showing
up and complaining about potholes in the
row and i'm just like dude what is this
like this is such an insane mode i don't
feel like i just want to shoot i just
want to shoot stuff and blow up a boss
and maybe kill an invader yeah or i just
want to win the game like it's so weird
that in gambit the least important part
is who wins
nobody cares like it's crazy nobody
cares about who wins and i wouldn't say
that they're like are you generally
would you do one of each type of blocker
for the bounty did you kill these guys
like
hopping into a match made game of gambit
is like watching uh game of thrones oops
all littlefinger that's what it's like
it's
like
everyone is just
trying to get some other ulterior motive
accomplished nobody cares but that's
like i mean i am 100 the same way
because i'll go load up some bounties
i'm like just if i'm gonna go in there
i'll grab some bounties but i'm like i
was working on triumph so i have to go
into gambit and use like
fusion rifles and swords so i'm going to
be running sword scavenger fusion rifles
not horrible right now because at least
particle deconstruction you can nuke
some people but i mean i'm gonna be
running a sword so i'm just gonna try
and run in and you know you're like oh i
need the bounty so i need to get super
kills for one of my stasis things that i
haven't still unlocked because i never
felt like going down that rabbit hole
i'm like okay so i'm gonna go in there
with like super i'm like okay i'm
waiting in the middle where's the next
place okay new enemies over here fresh
enemies that i can go for by myself so i
can get the most kills max
yeah like it is so bad
yeah strikes are like sometimes you're
like fighting people for objectives but
nobody gives a damn about
gambit objective at this point all you
want to do is just like what do i have
to work on i don't want to get out of
there as soon as possible yeah i want to
do my objectives and that does not
include winning the game yeah
it's all purgatory everybody's just
trying to move on to the next like place
no we're we're all just here because
because we're not where we want to be
right now that's all it is
i think what annoys the only thing that
annoys me is sometimes the bounties are
done in such a way that you can't
complete them within the three
match requirements for the pinnacle oh
they gotta do another one now yeah
i gotta go like oh this is a useless
match i don't even get a pinnacle for
this what the hell man yeah it's like
remember to put your ghost on that gives
you some type of
gambit bonus or something like that i
always got to remember to do stuff
that's my only thing that i'm like all
right that part is annoying
yeah
yeah then you remember how excited you
used to get when you saw the meatball
i used to get so excited like oh the
steaks are so much higher now and now i
see meatball and i'm like great this is
going to take longer i'm going to be
stuck in this match for longer than i
want to be like it's so there's like 600
and i'm sorry but like if one person has
like a hundred notes and my team has 15
because we got screwed over four times
they should not be able to still invade
and pay i'm like
yeah it's like and then somehow they've
got an invasion stocked up and then they
had they have their guy out we have 15
moats and then they're invading them
like
how is this not changed like that's one
of those that bugs me just because i'm
like as at a fundamental level when that
thing comes out wipe all invasions until
we get to that level if you want to give
us a shot which we don't have one anyway
at that point there's no like hey if
they've spawned it and you're you know
your moats now count for two that
doesn't even exist it doesn't there's no
catch-up mechanic to even try and let
you come back and have at least a little
bit of fun if you're that low you may as
well because everybody nukes the boss as
well now with linear fusions and other
things you just line it all up
it worked dude the bosses are dead so
fast if you're not even in the mix you
may as well just like sit down and emote
somewhere because it's gonna end real
fast anyway as a fact yeah i just wish
there was some motivation for winning
and gambit and rework like they still
came out on the climb you know like if
there was just some way to like
uh like incentivize people actually
playing well and working as a team
matches i think the map it would go it
would go a long way to making that mode
better but because no one's there to win
it's sort of just like you're just
waiting for the hell to end and trying
to get your you know personal weird side
objectives done while you're there so
it's so weird man it's such not a good
mode right now
yeah it is weird no i was just gonna say
yeah it is weird they just they haven't
touched it in so long and it's to a
point where i'm i i do ask the questions
like why is it still there
they want it to be a core playlist i
mean i know they want it to be a core
they put a lot of development time to
reap into building it even um
who's the guy that's a good idea yeah
who's the guy who talked to a gcx i'm
trying to
remember
adam pino got him yeah we talked to him
and he's like which one did you guys
like
but i mean in turn all we've ever had is
like we know pvp is getting some maps
not a lot a lot of refreshes but not not
much come in that direction but it's
like we lost two of the six gambit maps
and the mode is like you don't see
anything and it's like do they have some
pl i want to know if they have a plan
for it at all i don't even know how low
on the totem pole of priorities it is
but it is not high it seems yeah it's
it's definitely not
the way
i internalize it is
it's a bulletin board right now
it is clearly moved to the bottom and
for us even though we get annoyed that
we're doing trials for like six topics
in a row it feels like every last one we
do
but clearly their goal was all right
dead season
all the reason most resources are going
to be on the pve side towards which
queen however this current season we're
going to tweak and we're going to do
this with trials and we're going to mess
with we're going to turn that knob here
we're going to twist that knob there and
then this day and we're going to look at
the analytics and then they were like
what about give
oh oh yeah yeah
we'll get to you yeah there's a cork
board and somebody put a push pin on the
very bottom corner it's just like
dangling off the bottom like it barely
exists gambit is where pvp used to be
for the last three times that's what
gavin said and to be honestly i don't
have no sympathy for them right now like
they was the hot new mode i was at e3
with oh shout out to uh your boy or
dustin and sean off of finnegan when i
didn't believe it debuted i was able to
play a debut match at e3 we played it
for the first time together absolutely
that was so much fun i remember when the
mode came out it was crazy potential
crazy fun but like yeah they just
clearly right now once they took maps
away
and i'm like okay
i didn't understand that i understand
what we're doing with there but it's
just right now just that there's no
incentive like like travis is saying
like there's no incentive to win then
they scaled it back even further they
got rid of prime which was you know just
the whole suits remember everybody had
the suit and i'm there the rush of i'm
the the moat stacker yeah
go into reckoning earn some armor that
you use in gambit prime but the armor
itself that you earned and reckoning
does not make you better in reckoning
that alone was a problem with that
just the loop was so
non
supportive to itself like i'm gonna earn
armor here that benefits me here and
what what have they done recently for
again but they put a couple weapons in
there that have 600 perks on them so if
you want to try and have to go after a
good bottom dollar rule you get one and
you're like oh
you do the math on a good bottom dollar
you're not gonna see that one in 60 000
rolls like the odds there's so many it's
like you know
time lost weapons have like four perks
and four or like you know they're pretty
ironed down and then try the
gambit weapons like bottom
third and fourth column was like every
option possible oh yeah so you'll never
get that perfectly done that's purposely
though that's to keep you in the mode to
try to i will say historically
gambit weapons tend to be good like that
servant leader yeah is is real that's
the problem they they should just make
it so that you can only get the good
weapon if you win the match
just lock it behind a win then people
would actually play to win yeah i think
you actually might have people jumping
in there with teams you might actually
see some stuff you would see people if
you could guarantee a weapon or if you
had a bounty that you could grind out
towards that weapon
like even on europa you've got what is
his name our um
poorly talking gentleman of prison of
the arab eric barracks yeah you can go
do it
here you can go do one of the empire
hunts and at least go after the like the
bow if you want that bow which actually
biting wins is a pretty good one if you
want that bow you can go after that bow
there may be a lot of rolls but you
there's no way to specifically like hey
i want to go after bottom dollar i want
to go after servant leader and there's
still enough roles on those weapons that
would not harm anything to get bounties
directly onto
some of those weapons
whether it's like
you know a little quest like win a match
like get an invasion kill which people
would probably hate so don't always put
that in there sorry don't ever say that
um but it'd be like you know kill a
major kill like whatever it is like you
could do a couple of steps to go after a
role it doesn't have to be dramatic but
do some way to go after that type of
stuff i think i agree i do miss gambit
pinnacles though gabby pinnacles was
fire everybody was delirium what was it
breakneck
except for that had the same problem of
people just doing the
bounty quest stuff
everybody just had machine guns and they
were fighting over the heavy ammo to get
machine gun kills and they're just like
dude this is so annoying they just need
to
this is like a big problem with destiny
in general like every mode kind of has
this problem you know you hop into
crucible at the beginning of the season
and everybody's using the same linear uh
fusion rifle as they're trying to grind
out the catalyst or the quest or
whatever and it's sort of just uh it's
sort of a problem in destiny in general
that i think they've never really
addressed which is like people aren't
there to do the thing that they're
supposed to be doing ever the only mode
that's safe from it is raids like people
actually play raids to win but every
other game mode they're there to like do
something else it's so weird yeah but
gambit's by far the worst yeah it's like
but they aren't the worst offender it's
definitely worth it yeah it's like
that's one of those where if they would
ever do just like kill guardians or
combatants with this thing and it's no
it's like go in here with the linear
shin rifles you got 50 and crucible
because they want to put people in that
playlist and
go kill one gambit boss and then go to
strikes and kill like 500 people there
it's like they want to populate the
bosses but it's so frustrating to do
that because then you force them in if
somebody wants to go grind it out in
strikes let them do that and then when
they come to the crucible they turn
around and somebody who may be average
at crucible like this guy tries to get
linear fusion rifle kills
which those are somewhat amos is a
little easier like you can kind of make
some of those happen but like you needed
sniper kills for one of the pursuit
weapons um i can i remember the one that
the the ammo forgiveness one that
everybody was
up in arms about
yeah revoker like you had to go get
sniper kills like some people just be
like i suck at sniping i'm never gonna
get that weapon now there's incentive to
go kind of try and learn but sniping is
a hard one
but then you force people into those
situations and then some maps aren't
even built for that
you go get on like anomaly and you're
like well i'm not sniping here this is
just a wasted match of what i'm trying
to work on right now
yeah i know we're ragging on a lot of
stuff guys right now it's it it happens
sometimes but
time of year you know how we go
this is a cyclical thing
we don't know what type of relationship
we're in we know this that's not new
you know and like i said for me i i take
the travis approach which is like
i'm never going to put myself in a
situation where i'm going to get myself
all angry and worked up because it is
boring i know what it does right i know
what it is can you do it though conch we
all cry
you know i've done it i i mean clearly
i'm very guilty of doing it so my new
approach is just like look you know he
taught me we used to fight was it when
we went flashpoint about this type of
stuff he was like he's like go play some
other game no i would have lived in this
world i would i used to be the guy i was
i was the guy he's like play something
else until you don't hate it and that's
what i do and i'm like i'm getting
things done and then when i come back
and then sometimes i do what travis does
which is like i'll won't
burn through
every
objective to the t for you know i'm not
doing the tail you're not gonna be a
streamer and be like i played everything
too fast now i have nothing to play
nothing to play
and then you mad and i'm like no i still
got little a little check bar shout out
to gj he's in there shout out to uh back
from which cortez in there you know they
run him every once in a while they're
like yo you want to run um a last wish
see if you get it get yourself a 1k you
know what i'm saying kind of thing shout
out somebody's doing firecrackers i
don't know what the hell's going on my
mouth sorry i hear that that's it
i don't know november 4th we
firecrackers i don't know about i have
is there got
no idea actually there is it's diwali oh
is that what the oh i've seen that
popping up in a couple places yeah i'm
like something going on i'm like what is
happening in my area but um yeah so it's
like i'm not gonna get myself worked up
but i think for me it's like okay what's
what i usually do is i set milestones
okay so in november did everything i
need to do i got my trials gone and then
from now banner is nothing in there i
need
grandmasters anything i really need i
got a good plug one already
cool
and now it's like all right i am gearing
up for that 30th anniversary so end of
the month
that's when i start to ease my way back
in all right let's go down and i'm a
firm believer that bungie rng is is is
literally the algorithm is designed that
when i come back i'm going to get guy
rolls and a whole bunch of things
because i feel me and teddy have had
this conversation that when you are away
they incentivize you to get better like
god roll stuff to keep you to stay come
back when you know you've returned so
that's why
just you know check in see what's going
on he tells me it's safe all right safe
or at all i'll dip my toe in there see
what's going like that water feels okay
today yeah okay i did my freddie there
see what's going on in the pool
got other stuff going on it's all good
well yeah this last weekend i will say
the twitter world was on fire pretty
much
uh due to trials this one thing that has
been going on uh shout out to
aberral which i'm probably saying wrong
i apologize
um he said kids play with firecrackers
on diwali so
you nailed it travis was travis was
right on there
but representative trials win based
matchmaking we had the speculation
this may not go that well and then there
were some thoughts on twitter before it
ever happened the more wins you get the
farther the matchmaking got
question more questionable it would be
and they're like lack of incentive to
play and all of those things
man did trials just absolutely light it
up this weekend with
just thumbs downs everywhere in every
different way you could probably say
that
with regards to the matchmaking on this
one now i played this weekend as a solo
player
uh just i got to my seven wins
um nice probably hit or miss wasn't too
crazy
but i didn't been to the lighthouse now
right oh we did that still no
bro oh wow get on with this
at some point i will have to yes i had
family in town for like a couple
weekends and
yeah it's been weird um
but the big thing was the more wins you
got
over the course of the weekend
accumulation whether it was on 20
different cards or one card you would be
starting to match with people with five
wins you're matching people five wins
you play seven cards and you've got 25
wins so far well you're matching people
at 25 wins no matter how they got there
and then you had people who probably
just ran all weekend winning a bunch of
matches and you've got bungie saying
well the people who played lots of
matches
but if you are on the bleeding edge of
win counts your matchmaking times could
easily be over or anywhere from two to
five minutes
they said the average match count was up
10 seconds so we even talked about that
last time saying you know wait a little
longer for decent matchmaking times you
know what i'm totally fine with it 10
seconds don't care like not a big deal
to most of us if you're saying five
minutes to start a match you may as well
start a match go in the other room make
yourself a snack stop by the restroom
come back then you might have actually
found something
um shout out to siva tech member for
three months thank you uh make trials
great again had to thank you for that by
the way siva appreciate that
uh
they said overall games played was down
about a third they said average to
low-skilled players they had about the
same play time but higher skilled
players were literally
about a third less play time about two
and a half hours less a lot less matches
played and that's basically what it led
to is anybody who was gonna play more
and more
had less and less incentive to do so
because if you're grinding out wins and
that was the problem with people trying
to go flawless for example travis like
the issue with that would be people
would try to go flawless well they get
to five wins and they lose okay well you
gotta reset the card go back well now
you're starting in the five win
matchmaking well you win about five more
well then you lose again at five then
you start over now you're in the ten win
matchmaking you do it again and it just
like increments on so now your first
game
is that like 27 wins and you're trying
to get through a card to get the
flawless and you're already in like top
tier matchmaking pool
that's where the issue lies for people
who are playing more and more so there
was less incent like if you didn't get
on your first card
you may as well have given up and even
more incentive not to play until the
last day than i think we've had before
so for me while i got to my seven wins
and i stopped because i got you know
pinnacle got some engrams reset it's my
second reset by the way and trials are
up
twice i've done that now
i've gone to ten thousand with that man
twice
and i'm like what is wrong with me
um it's just fun to practice because i
tend to need to work on it a lot so it's
a way to do that
so as a solo player for me this season
overall actually just allowing me to
jump in whether i get shellacked or not
like there's still some games i get to
like practice and learn on work on my
skills kind of getting better at dodging
and awareness and radar and those types
of things
but in general this weekend was not
liked by a lot of people and you got to
the point where if you didn't do it
early you were kind of done
yeah
so
bungie at least listened
yeah because i know what everybody
actually wants and we still can't seem
to get that
while there are some positives most of
the data is either negative or neutral
combined with the feedback on social
media channels
please let's go how do you define that
feedback trash
like i don't know this is fine yeah this
has fueled our decision to move back to
purely card based matchmaking with a
flawless pool for the foreseeable future
now my one question to that
yes everyone on social media which you
know they look at or the sentence right
there and this is where you're going
once week
one
that is literally all they want to do is
to try week one again and we can't seem
to get that now i wanted to ask both of
you
if you have an idea why
oh i do it's so fun and i talked to we
we had we you and travis talked about
this in the dm
and it's so funny like the community
will scream from the rooftops
this is what needs to happen right for
weeks
make it like this do it like this right
and every week we hear about the day
and i think it's just funny to me that
finally the data has shown that it is
either negative or neutral as far as the
engagement they talk about the games
down and the blowout rate went up or
whatever and it's just so funny because
to me this is analysis by paralysis and
i think they just get into that data bag
where they have to have the data say
that it's it's clearly that and and look
i get it you know there's there's the
whole vocal minority and the majority
and i know they're trying to service you
know
a whole lot of casual people i'm pretty
sure exactly i i get it yeah i get it
but it's like
you know to me it's also when when the
community has that much vitriol
collectively
right you know i feel that there should
be some concessions sometimes where we
don't have to wait the you know three to
four weeks we don't have to wait three
to four months to to say hey you know
what let's at least tweak in this
direction and i think that's what it is
it's just it
there it it it's so funny because
everybody said week one was the most fun
they had you know kind of thing and is
it perfect no but to me this is this is
a clear-cut example
that the data again
moves them that is the end-all be-all
and no matter how much you scream right
they will we're listening
but to the data and the data set at this
time so now all right you know what card
y'all we're going to do we got to do
that's just my thought on it
travis where you at on this one since i
know you got an opinion i don't know if
you haven't been in it that much
probably but where do you
yeah where do you think i mean why or
what would you like to see out of all of
this i know okay so what you really want
to see we probably kind of already
yeah yeah we've kind of already talked
about this ad nauseam i don't really
have a lot of opinions about this like i
think we all agreed last week that this
theory for matchmaking probably wasn't
gonna work out and now we know that it
did it didn't work out right like
they're gonna go back to the old way of
doing it which seemed to have engaged
more engagement and that sort of stuff
but i think it's very clear that like
you know none of these modes really seem
to be working for the hardcore because
you're seeing like the amount of matches
played like going down quite a bit but
if it's not if it's also not working for
the casuals then they're losing on both
ends right so they should probably pick
one or the other or come up with a
different hypothesis if they're trying
to serve both but yeah i
my i was not surprised at all by this
when they announced the system i was
like all right well this seems like it's
going to be a really bad experiment and
then it was and now they're reversing it
so whatever you know you win some you
lose some but i hope they learned
something at least so yeah i was like
neil and chad saying week one made the
average joes like me feel like trials
now what was week one somebody remind
people who may have like missed the memo
or whatever was going on can one of you
guys describe what week one
was
it didn't have a flawless pool right
that was one thing i know it didn't have
the flawless pool it was literally just
uh you can play alone or with another
person but they didn't change anything
else yeah yeah so they had their own
well they added cross play they added
they changed the reward system so that
it was more accessible but everything
that is currently in trials now was the
same except for
uh the way that they did matchmaking and
the way that they uh there was no
freelance player it was just card based
no flawless pool doesn't matter what you
did right yep and i think that i
honestly think that the reason i think
people are getting it confused the
reason week one was so good is because
it was new and uh there was a higher
player base there was rewards to chase
after and all that stuff so i think it
might just be a victim of the fact that
it's so late in the season and i think
player numbers are going to be lower
regardless of what happens
like this is a point where again i would
wonder it's like as bungie and it's like
you have the vocal people you have the
people with like you know
the aztec cross there's like 500 000
subs and he'll make a trials update
video literally after any piece of news
about it so like there are people who
are going to touch a lot of people who
play this game so if you get updates to
a point and finally if bungie's like all
right all you people screaming from the
rafters you want this let's see what it
looks like now well just
to me that would either
let us see what we think is there but we
know actually isn't
or let it be like hey this is an
experiment we didn't think it was going
to be there but honestly everybody had a
good time like
if that's the one thing everybody is
asking for just take out the flawless
pool
and card based only
go back to week one
you're doing so many experiments right
now why not do that i don't i don't see
the reason not to
and again they may say see data but
again even neil in there was just saying
he's like average jill's like that if i
if i matched with the three stack
probably figured that wasn't going to be
great but if i matched with
an other you know if i did hit up a solo
group
i kind of figured i was like all right
let me put my try hard hat on let me see
how i can do let's get in the mix a
little bit and i had some matches you
know the three stacks now that's where i
like the freelance pool if you take out
the flawless pool but if you just go
week one with freelance i am golden to
me
because then you have
and honestly as travis had said
previously the regular one should be
three stacks so you don't have like twos
getting in this weird mix if you're two
you probably need to find one more
because that's a weird situation because
your one-off's probably not gonna make
you better
freelances or threes but like the
flawless pool
is weird because you give people
incentive not to play for two days right
that's my weird part about this like
if i jump in on the early onset of
trials on say i do myself video and i
jump on it one for whatever reason
i'm gonna be up against the people who
are trying to knock out cards early and
that's not good then you get over to the
flawless pool which again has other
people who are better than me but have
waited to let the other people get into
the flawless pool try and do the same
thing when i've been shellacked the same
way so now we're gonna go no freelance
this time and we're gonna have the
flawless pool and my curiosity is gonna
be to see how many three stacks i see
come not this weekend because iron
banner is going on but next weekend like
how many three stacks i see come
sunday afternoon when they're like oh
flawless pool just switched over now
it's my turn to get the they get the
easy run now that i know some of those
people are out of there like so you
literally have two times where you have
full two days where you shouldn't play
and then you have the beginning of
sunday where you shouldn't play and then
you limit people depending on where they
live regions and time zones and stuff
where you leave them like half a day
where they actually probably have a
reasonable chance when their flawless
pool is doing the filtering that it
should
the the problem i see is
the flawless pool
while in theory i understand what
they're trying to do the problem is they
they can't avoid the fact
that caring is a big part of the
community it's a it's a huge part it's a
huge part for streamers and they want to
do that so you're limit you're literally
saying during these specific days after
what is it sunday or whatever it is
you can't carry right and that is
angering people because that is a huge
you know part of it so again it to me
it's it always comes to the data it's
just sad that it takes
this long for to get to the conclusion
sometimes that the community wants and
ultimately feels was the best and um
yeah that's what it is it's still it's
still a tweaking it's still the you know
the over analytical with the number kind
of thing and you just hope that they
meet in the middle that's all i'm saying
like me in the middle not everything has
to be letter to the law
wait for the data to show that it's a
successful thing or not and that's just
where they are so we'll see we'll see i
don't know sometimes they just got to go
by feel a little bit more and i know
they really are against that a lot of
the time yeah they are yeah but i was
like at this point when you do have it
this is literally the perfect time
next week
like okay season stuff's over 30th
anniversary pop is not back
that would literally be the time i think
for the try the week one stuff just to
give people and be like
now they could at least give us the data
on
what we think week one was so special to
see if it really was and otherwise
people are gonna never know and i think
that's the other thing is if you don't
tell
while they're the vocal minority it's
one more week of trials and half the
people are playing half hard anyway
playlist is going down
let the experiment happen and go out so
you can at least have that data and you
can also either shove it back in our
face and be like hey guess what it sucks
you were wrong
or you could have people be like it it
could use a few tweaks but we're getting
closer with that something would be
worthwhile i think there
and this is like the perfect time and i
think they're going to miss it that's my
worry is like this would literally be
the perfect time for them to do it low
population before the pop to see what
it's going to be like in these odd
seasons to see if it does work that's
just my thought
i guess
i mean well i was like and that's the
thing it's like
no i was like
whatever in that part i just said like
it's just
i love to tweak it i do you know i don't
mind tweak tweak tweak tweak but again
to me the issue comes down to what
travis said and what i said as far as
where we met in the middle with our
age-long debate right which is you need
the competitive aspect of some type of
ranking system
to get people more in line with the
skills of who they should be facing
against right
then you also have to have
rewards to make people go in the list
and the thing is right now there are not
both
so
as the rewards have gone
listen at the start of trials the
population is going to decrease
regardless right there's always going to
be some level of drop-off but when
there's again there's not a lot of
rewards and then if people feel like
they're a getting stopped getting
crushed you know what i'm saying or a or
b
crushing everybody like and they're not
feeling any type of challenge because
there's the way the the matchmaking is
set up it's going to affect it it's
going to affect that's it so what i'm
hoping
is with both of those those things again
it's a long shot don't know if it's
gonna be witch queen hopeful hope for
hoping it's which queen don't know that
that these things are actually in place
or being set up to be in place kind of
like how long it took us to get
anti-cheat we all knew anti-cheat we all
knew that was a problem you know it just
takes them a long time you know and i
don't i don't know if it's a resource
thing i don't know if it's a priority
thing but i just don't know how long
it'll be
before we get that that that's the thing
i'm at right now i don't i don't know
because which let's be honest witch
queen in itself is a huge rollout
they're talking raid you're talking to
savithoon story
theoretically is it is the trials aspect
truly going to get
fixed in that season
i would lean no right i would mean it
would still need more time right and i'm
not trying to be negative but it's just
you know that's just how how these
things work but i'm curious to try like
what do you think on that level like
where are you at with it as far as like
the end game goal to maybe get closer to
both of the things that both me and you
want
yeah um
i guess i would say they're closer now
than they were right like
the it it it is baby steps like you said
and i know i can get like pretty um
intense when we talk about the stuff
because
it's sort of you know it's it's it's my
mode right like i i it's why it's why i
log on for me
earning weapons in a raid isn't about
having a cool weapon it's about just
being able to make somebody cry and
crucible like that's why i want those
weapons you know so uh
yeah when i got 1 000 voices when i got
vex mythic class it was all for the joy
of hurting somebody's feelings
in a crucible playlist
i hate i hate that you got a new mic cog
because i can never hear you laugh your
capital is always
such joy but your your mic your mic
filters it out
um
yeah um
so
like uh
but but honestly like the fact that
they're even paying attention to trials
during this downtime is such a like huge
uh gesture the fact that they're they
clearly care about getting more players
in uh and and making it more rewarding
and making it more accessible like all
the changes they made to the roard
system the fact that cross plays here
all that stuff is like tremendously good
i just think like as we keep saying
every week there needs to be a way to
make it actually competitive for
if the goal of trials is to make it a
competitive mode and not purely card
based which i'm not even saying that
that's a thing they could make it just
card based and
put a competitive mode somewhere else
comp i think is is long overdue for some
sort of uh makeover in terms of it
actually being competitive but i just
think like
to your point cog people care about
rewards um
i think that that's only
that's only partly the reason people
play when it comes to crucible which
we've talked about but um i think that
if they made seasonal rewards like if
you get up to the diamond tier at the
end of that season if you have reached
that tier at any point during the season
you get those rewards you reach out
to me yeah yeah you received you
received the highest rewards of however
high you were able to get in the bracket
forgotten days yeah yeah yeah that was a
huge you stayed in that bed you stayed
in it baby that's and that's a good
correlation right how they had yeah it
was
competitive aspect to reach that tier
right yeah and versus in a good reward
with a nice unique perk that it was a
perfect marriage announcement i don't
even think that they need to do not
forgotten like if you if you got a like
a package of rewards for getting to
silver if you're a bronze player and
you're getting the bronze rewards
because that's all you normally get
you're working to get to that silver and
let's just say silver gives you a couple
more ascendant shards and it gives you
uh you know a package of uh other
materials that you might want and it
gives you uh
a um
a
skin for the the seasonal crucible uh
pvp weapon or something like that
you know you would you would play for
that and then people at the diamond
level you know if they have their own
exclusive skin for that same gun that's
going to be bragging rights that they
could walk around with and you know or
glow on a weapon that they wouldn't
normally have or
uh i know people would probably be mad
at this especially paul tassie but if
like the highest tier give you access to
a um a shader
that you couldn't you couldn't get
through other ways you know and then you
get those rewards at the end of the
season that way it's not just play this
week to get this weapon play this week
to get this armor it's play all season
and aspire to climb the ladder so that
you can get that that big packaging yeah
that's okay it's kind of how comp used
to be
it's actually it's more like closely to
what rocky league does and what
hearthstone is really good at it also
that the witcher gwent card game has a
really good seasonal rank system um
something like that like when i see
those packages it gives me more fuzzies
it makes me like ooh i'm gonna play all
season and i'm gonna like try really
hard to get as high as i can in that
ladder um knockout city also is another
game that's actually doing pretty uh
pretty well at that uh system right now
so there's so many so many games that do
it and i know people say like somebody
said in the comments jokingly the rich
get richer it doesn't have to be
uh stuff that's actually useful
if if it were just
a cosmetic
take one thing or how about this if
people are mad about that they don't
want cosmetics locked behind skill then
just uh give us an item that is
is also sold on eververse
that you cannot buy with bright dust so
you can pay real money or you can do
that in the game
don't do that
why not
no because they want people buying power
and that's something they said they will
never do no
a cosmetic oh cosmetic sure i'm saying
i'm saying if they sold a cosmetic and
they made it
with real money
or you get it
yeah maybe that i would say oh you could
do like hey if you want the actual true
like angel wing glow like those are the
ones that always stand out it's the
ornaments from trials before the like
wing ornament was like fantastic walking
on the field like dude
be like okay
and you could be like
yeah but i was like okay and then if you
want to buy a you could buy like a baby
wing version of it from eververse like
if you want some look but you gotta earn
the good one and i think also
when don't mask is saying the rich get
richer
when i sit there and make guide videos
part of me is saying like hey for those
of you who don't want to do raids and
other things that's what even why i
wouldn't use something like tyrion of
heaven as like a solar bow
but there's also a point where
why should you run those top level
things it's like there needs to be
something out there like
that's like what's the what did
everybody grind their hindquarters off
for when the comp weapons were there
when there was exclusive weapons at the
end of that like it doesn't have to be
at the 5500 legend level or you know
diamond one that's where you need to
have like
that's where you need to have that
ornate name plate looking thing going on
to be like now you see a nameplate with
like a diamond sitting up there be like
okay that's actually cool but like maybe
a stage below that or somewhere in the
middle then you can start working for
you know weapon and the weapon with like
another perk slot or something like that
but they need to have tears of that
stuff there needs to be some loot in
there i don't want it just cosmetics
because even for me the annoyance of
cosmetics in say a dungeon
this pisses me off because half the half
of them end up in everest anyway
yeah remember but it was like yeah
i get that
the reason i was saying maybe i'll also
offer it never verse is because there's
some people who
will kind of bristle with the idea of
there being anything exclusive behind
getting to like diamonds tears they just
need to get over that they need to get
over that
yeah i agree with you there yeah i'm
with you because
let me just get supportive because the
thing is
it's unfair that pvp is penalized and
not the way pve is because there's stuff
okay
you're gonna have six people you gotta
do a raid you gotta do this extremely
hard pinnacle content so why can't pvp
have that equivalent why is it taken out
of it like the the people who have that
skill level that are like like travis
said like you i remember bro like
mountaintop revoke i was trying to get
that 5500 i was you know trying to stay
in that comp playlist because it was the
aspiration you saw that dude you're like
oh you got that you know that that gun
or whatever it was it it made you stay
in the mode and it's like they've really
gone away from but i think they went
away from it for the wrong reason i
think they went away from it because
they were concerned about balancing the
problem is they stripped the mold
completely and then never put anything
of any value back into it and i think
that's where the disconnect is it's just
again it doesn't have to be the level
could you imagine
an exotic
that was indeed i know that would get
people pissed i don't get people but
look there's 1k there's eyes of tomorrow
there's literally vex mythic class right
now is the most busted gun right now in
destiny and the worst thing is there's
so much rng you don't even know if you
can even control it right you can't even
control it so why can't pvp have one
that may be tied tied to your your rank
system you don't say like something like
give me like exotic ornaments up there
too like i mean that's the thing that
ranking system needs to be comp needs
like as we're talking about all of these
things comp needs a vast overhaul
to matter because right now there's no
point i see the and they even know glory
playlist doesn't matter because it's not
even in the pinnacle reward
loot it's only for powerfuls you get
seven rounds and you get a powerful and
every other node that you normally can
see is pinnacle i'm like
you really don't care about that mode
because it's not even a pinnacle grind
for you because so you don't care it's
like
it's at that level but yeah i was like
if trials could have some kind of
ranking
that would be fantastic they seem to be
pushing away so that mode gets more
people in it because now you have the
issue with like if you play a lot like
me i kind of i don't have the god rolls
but i definitely have options for every
role i got a decent igneous i got a
decent sniper
um
and you're going to have options that
start to say do i really need to put my
time into this and the problem is if
they do an annual refresh of loot to
trials that's not frequent enough that's
the other issue behind trials is now if
you're saying
yeah now you're saying if it's like
a little more casualized easier loot to
get by time that you spend in the
playlist and those types of things if
you're gonna put it at that level then
that loot needs to be much more
frequently updated and that is one thing
i know they're trying to build up the
teams for
they've said they're like trying to
build up the team so we can have more
options coming out and more weapons that
come they do have a decent amount of
weapons now in these seasons that come
out you've got decent amount of like
refreshes which they're kind of leaning
on at some point that'll kind of run out
of gas but
um
at some point yeah that needs to get
some love and there needs to be a
seasonal refresh for that otherwise it's
like you know you getting a witch queen
and if there's not a new set for witch
queen well i just got it all last season
that just took take one of my pillars
out yeah that's also the problem with uh
not forgotten is it was the only reward
for so many seasons yeah yeah it was it
should be to be fair though it did take
multiple seasons to earn that i kind of
liked that kind of aspirational nature
to it but i kind of think they can do
both right like they can make it
accessible and make it so that
everybody's playing at their level and
gets some reward for aspiring to get to
that next tier above them and uh give
items that aren't game breaking like i
don't even think there should be
exclusive weapons i think it should all
be cosmetic but they should be badass
cosmetics that people really want like
to get to that they want to go from
silver to gold because they know that
the gold ornament set is
incredibly like cool and iconic or you
know they like you said like they get
the little diamond symbol next to their
name if they get to diamond tier i think
everybody should have a seasonal
ranking for competitive playlists and
heck do it for other ones give them a
seasonal ranking for
uh raids and pbe stuff give them a
seasonal ranking for gambit if people
are into that i just think that there
needs to be some sort of reason to like
continue in this loop and unique rewards
for all of that and we know that they
can make
unique cosmetic rewards because there's
so much in eververse dude hire like one
more guy that just makes eververse items
but they're not available in eververse
instead they go into uh you know a
separate uh pool for rewards like we
know they can do that i definitely could
do it they definitely do it and the
reason why i push back with the people
is like oh you know this new rat is
getting killed we can't keep the casuals
down and i was like look the reason why
it's not gatekeeping if it's a if it's a
cosmetic item that's ridiculous no but i
want to push back on the weapon part
because here's my thing yeah the reason
why i should have my yes
you know why i'm a pushback because what
happens when the new season starts we
log in and we're literally giving with
the horde you're giving the money yeah
you're
paying ten dollars you are giving what's
the what's the limit i still hate that
laurence driver yeah laurence sorry
here you go knock yourself out new thing
for the exactly i want that to stop so
hard it's not even funny i gotta go
seriously that bugs the hell out of me
you want to talk about devaluing an
exotic
as you literally said you log in on day
one here it is yeah you gotta grind for
a catalyst but i'm like here's your new
exotic for the season i'm like where's
the value in that it's a unique weapon
sure they are usually typically very
cool like tiku's divination
lauren's driver very cool weapon
definitely has some functionality to it
and you know avoid sucking up people and
blowing them up like they did some cool
stuff with these why did you give it to
me it's not even a request involved just
day one blah ten dollar ten minutes
you aspired with your ten dollars to get
rank 35 because that's the free way to
get it don't mask that you can get it
for free at rank 35 which isn't even
that hard to get
you'll get that anyways so it's like
it's either time or money which either
one but there's no
accomplishment to it there's no
story to it there's no
are you kidding me i sent you guys both
the article about the lawrence driver
like the science behind the weapon you
remember me sending you that article are
you telling me there's no way you can't
get a quest in there that somehow
explains what's going something like
anything behind what this thing does
like tiku's divination i want to know
what where the i want to do a quest to
get that one solar bow that like locks
on and you got exploding multiple
targets now i'm like dude this is good
season passes
yeah season passes yeah and if you tell
me who's gonna die in which queen before
the damn thing launches too i'm just
gonna be pissed again
okay i do actually like i feel like when
it comes to okay so would you guys want
to know
um
right now
would you want to know that cortana's in
halo infinite right now before it
launches
that's a completely different question
play it dirty oh no you're not
questionable
here 86 has been killed sorry for
spoilers how's that different
here's the distinction
cade dying is the premise of forsaken
it's the jumping off point it's not the
big reveal at the end so
the halo
infinite i'm going to guess that cortana
coming back it's not going to be the end
of the game either i feel like i bet you
i bet you i bet you it's not the premise
though the the the the parallel between
halo infinite if you want to compare
apples to apples would be knowing that
it starts with master chief losing a war
and humanity being in a super dark place
which we do know that's the premise of
halo infinite just like cade dying is
the premise of forsaken so it's
different learning the premise of an
expansion the first thing you learn when
you boot it up is very different it
would be like if in forsaken the trailer
going to the dreaming city if it showed
you going to the dreaming city in the
forsaken trailer then i would be like
all right that's messed up but it's
literally the premise like and i feel
the same way about a about witch queen
the premise is
the first thing we're going to see we
all know is going to be the trailer of
you know the hive becoming uh becoming
guardians and all that
but that's the premise it's literally
like the it's the very first thing you
see but that's the difference okay
that's the difference of like premise
but if it was like okay what if the part
of the premise is that
aikora and vanguard are somehow put in
prison or one of them is killed and we
know that beforehand because that's what
kicks off what like savithoon busts out
and
like i don't want to know that stuff in
her hand
but here's the thing if you if you boot
up the game in february and the first
thing you learn is that stuff the whole
prison stuff whatever you just did the
fanfic you just wrote for the audience
yeah i don't know if that's the if
that's if that
if that's the first thing you see why do
you care about seeing that in february
versus right now because it's gonna be
the first thing you see anyway right so
it's just like they're giving you a
preview of the game
he hates that if it's literally the
first thing you see he what's the
mystery he wants i don't know but
the mystery is after the the
establishment of
of the game like if it's if it's part of
the literally the jumping off point i'm
i actually agree with e most of the time
i just think that destiny actually does
a pretty good job at it and that they
tend to not show you anything past like
the first 20 minutes
of the thing you know it's like if it's
if it like movie trailers are the worst
you guys movie trailers will show you
like we'll show you the spoiler at the
seventy-five percent mark of that one
one of my buddies actually stopped
watching basically every trailer on
account of that which is no smart thing
to do yeah i don't like industry i i
will say like some was it force awakens
was one of the best trailers i've seen
in a while because they didn't know much
so good you have no idea actually star
wars not only i don't want to get off on
a star wars tension because you're sorry
keep it small keep it short but i will
keep it small star wars actually goes a
step further and records separate
sequences that they have no intention of
putting in the movie
just
you know the only annoying thing about
that though is because most movies
you're looking for that one point to
happen the whole time when you get
things you're like where was that like
what was that one thing i saw exactly if
you don't watch the trailer that's
perfect i love you guys
i think every i think every movie should
do that and i think video games haven't
gotten to that point yet where they're
like starting to spoil what's in the
game
the trailers are way better and i think
it's because they have an advantage they
can show gameplay they don't have to
focus on the story right they can just
show you shooting things out of context
whereas movies they kind of have to put
story in there because that's all they
have right
but i i think they've done a better job
and i think the things you're
complaining about are like first 15
minutes stuff if it's first 15 minutes i
i i give them a pass but if they would
have shown the dreaming city in the
trailer i would have been like oh hell
okay so there's a line somewhere there's
a lot for sure there's a line for and
actually my threshold is pretty short my
threshold is like if it's if it's past
the first hour i don't want to see it in
the trailer that's my threshold and but
destiny's pretty good about not showing
it i think shout out to forte right
that's just my opinion uh he said had
bad luck sure for the five dollar super
chat had bad luck solo cooing win three
then reset win five reset dang bro i
look up now i have 23 rins and going
flawless just got harder ran over so
yeah anyway i had to throw that one out
there but
but yeah we're in this weird
we have the time for them to experiment
we'd like to see it
we know the story's got this weird
timing of like we need the final chapter
we don't know when we're getting it uh
we know the 30th anniversary doesn't
really connect to things got a couple
holiday things coming up we are
we're in a weird month right now for
destiny granted we also have like lost
art forza a couple
a forever backlog right now so it's a
good thing but if you're looking to try
and like as you asked kind of in the
very beginning of this whole discussion
how's destiny doing for you
it's weird right now it's not the best
it's
if you've i mean i'm season pass rank
205 i think
i played more than i honestly expected i
would trials probably helped a decent
amount of that uh going through the
season man some of those seasonal
challenges be like 205 to 209 like just
wow jump
so i've done most of the seasonal
challenges actually as well and i have
the very specific ones that i haven't
like naturally done use swords and
fusion rifles in gambit or something i'm
like alright i haven't done that yet
obviously
but it's like we are in this weird place
right now where it's like
like what i mean it is it's like i
dude
we always have that the seasonal lull
yeah but this one's weird it's weirder
because of the story stuff yeah it's
also weird just because like we know
what's gonna happen at the beginning of
which queen and so yeah it's like where
how are we gonna get there and my my
theory is that literally nothing's gonna
happen until the witch queen comes out
and that trailer that we saw is like the
next story beat that's honestly what i
think is gonna happen i think the the
20th anniversary will be a complete
different distraction and i think we
won't hear anything from saboteur maybe
we'll get like one extra thing but it
will not be substantial and then all of
a sudden it'll just jump to witch
queen's master plan and we'll be like
what the hell that happens so quick
we'll get whiplash that that's what i'm
excited for like i listen i i i feel you
i know you i know where you at i know
you hate the reveal i think the thing
just comes down it's the perfect
marketing tool man
she's so listen we've been talking about
sabbath doom for so long in the lore
like her name and her appearance itself
is such a marketing bliss they're going
to kill her with that to me all i care
about is again like the transition what
happened what what how long we have to
wait for that oh
yeah we got that's what's right
bungie 30th is going to be fun for me i
want to see how they handle it i want i
want you going to get the dylan beanie
yeah i'm going to do the beauty i'm
going to get all that stuff in it i'll
get it sorry it's 30 it's 30th
anniversary i think we've been saying 20
or yeah
but yeah either way i said this one yeah
they've been around for a while it's
quite impressive no no they never
existed before halo combat evolved shut
up everyone i'm just kidding
2001. that's when they existed all right
uh
look i'm i'm excited for that i i'm
excited for galley low-key i want to say
i know yeah but i i wanted to see how it
does i was hoping it would never come
back honestly this was the in case of
emergency button
i get what it is we've talked about that
but i was like i was really hoping it
wasn't going to make it into this
because like we've had an issue this is
going to be the third time you want to
talk about reissues yeah third time and
but what it is but i told you it's you
it's that big red button that the
commissioner gordon button when you know
the season's too long
you know
it was a paddock movie they knew they
had no expansion coming out until
february what are they going to do with
this community what the hell galahon
button baby to the day you
hit that bloody clothes all through so
but i do want to see the dungeon i want
to know what that's about even even with
all the controversy and stuff like that
i think that's going to be my fun
distraction but when that when you tell
me
yo
story beat
mara something happened don't cyrus
something that's when that's when you'll
see twitter and be like oh i gotta log
on not yet yes no that when i get that
tweet that's what i am lit like i cannot
wait so yeah that's where i'm at right
now my guess that is gonna be february
8th
i'm gonna put a date on it
that is a long time but if you go
february 22nd back it up february two
weeks before because they usually give
like not a one week buffer but usually
two weeks
is how they've kind of been doing the
epilogue a little bit and that's my
guess i love how uh i love how bungie's
new move is to literally put things on
ice
like when they can't when they when
they're not ready to finish the story
they just like put aramis on ice they
put uh you know sabathune and a crystal
like
he said
yeah they
they just literally like that's their
move now it's like all right well we did
guys we didn't really finish this aramis
story we kind of ran out of uh out of
roadway here for the beyond light story
i don't know just
freezer
you know the problem with what happens
on the eighth when they unfreeze
whatever the crystal is it's gonna be
log in talk to mara watch the ritual if
there's a little cinematic or animated
storyboard or whatever they do and it's
gonna be over like uh david said in chat
it's gonna be fifth uh february eighth
in a minute but it's like literally five
minutes after the season starts
or you're gonna do one activity and it's
gonna be over you're gonna be done in 30
minutes and that's your one story
mission and then there's going to be
hype guardians that's my issue with
waiting that long
something that small never lives up to
the weight that we tend to get for it
the extended weight for that one thing
is usually done so quickly
if it was in the sequence of events it
was we banned then you got to know you
wait for which queen at least you kind
of get it in sequence
right and then they're going to have tr
like the trailer is going to do the hype
they need anyway
like you're going to see a trailer and
be like i'm here i'm ready yep sign me
up whatever i have to do for which queen
put me in i'm good to go like i'm good
to go coach but i was like the fact that
we're going to get that thing is going
to be like okay that was cool now we
know now we still gotta wait another
couple weeks but it's like if it would
have been
last month sometime or something like
that i think it's still gonna hit better
they just they just wanna combine it
because what's gonna happen is
yeah we gotta wait hella long right
we'll do this stupid way
february come be like okay oh story
advance okay okay then you know those
witch queen trailers are gonna stop of
course yeah and when no stopped pumping
everybody was talking slick about
destiny all of a sudden and the
population comes back and everything oh
my god did you see
it's the cycle baby it's the cycle you
know you you've been through this rodeo
you know what this does and destiny is
right where it is killing everything
like it always do so i i'm i'm not the
only problem is this time they've got
more competition than they've ever ever
had
but one thing i agree with travis though
i think their strategy is
they have shown whenever there's
competition sometimes you go on ice and
you just you just wait it out you know
you just do what you got to do but when
they hit
if you can withstand and to be let's be
honest single player games ain't really
going to affect destiny you know what
i'm saying like you'll go you know
you're playing
doesn't have the same okay
[Music]
you got to be another you know either
looter shooter or mmo in a space to have
some type of thing because what listen
when bungie comes outside
and that you know how twitter do when
that marketing blitz hit just with the
witch queen stuff before this well he's
like oh my god she's got she's got hive
guardians with oh my god you hear that
like it it's it's a whole different
animal that they need i hope everybody
in the marketing team gets raises
because literally they have saved this
game
every time every year of its existence
we do even on terrible season content
i've seen this worthy trailer
oh my god they're the greatest they
literally they they they owe a lot to
that squad for sure oh yeah i was like i
mean i know it's coming
i'll miss the activision days that was
uh i don't i don't know if you guys ever
actually i would have seen you there if
you were there but yeah uh
back in the day when activision was like
the thing that they used to do these
bougie events or they'd fly you up to
reveal
people in like the hangar right
that was well that one was like a one
day event but they used to do on-site
review events where they'd rent out like
this ho hotel you get three meals a day
and snacks and they put you up in the
hotel there was a week of my life where
i didn't leave a hotel literally i took
all my meals in the hotel i played
destiny in this massive room with all
these other press people in the hotel
and then at the end of the day i would
go back and just fall into a bed and
then wake up the next day to play my
destiny that was like my entire life
those were
speaking of like now that we're talking
about the marketing and pr team like
they i feel like they knew
oh if you give them like a cool
experience it'll kind of like color
their view of the game and so they used
to do these like
bougie
it was crazy man the champagne and
caviar even though the game sucks right
yeah exactly like that was the thing and
everybody would always be like you know
i would go there and i'd be like oh no
obviously i'm a totally like unbiased
objective reviewer uh you know doing
what i can but
it's like you make friends it's like
going it's like going to camp you know
like you're there with all your buddies
who also like the same things you do and
you're all
you feel special because you're getting
to go and play it first and you got all
the devs oh do you want to do an
interview with me let's let's talk right
now we'll talk about the art direction
of the game and it's like
here's the crazy thing right now and i
know i noticed that this data metric
does not represent the entire community
but look how impressive
we are all complaining right now how
dead it is and you know we're gonna have
to wait and then you're looking at the
current current players or something
i'm looking at just the xbox most play
games right now
destiny is number six in a dead
season with no loot and we're bitching
about
it's iron it's iron banner cog it's
always been iron banner that's what's
carried this game as far as it has got
so all this destiny killer that i hear
from other people that don't like the
game
they're literally in their worst
position right now in a long time right
during this this horrible seasonal low
and it's the sixth plague game what's
the concurrent what's what's the journal
on
on steam i got to probably i want to
know what's going on with the numbers
right now
what's inside steam charts
yeah you want to know 48 hours literally
next to warzone fortnite apex grand
theft call of duty black ops cold war
and there's destiny 2. by the way grand
theft auto 5.
grand theft auto 5 just surpassed
the number of ps2s sold yeah 156 million
or 157.
it has now sold more copies of that game
than they sold
consoles during the piece september of
2021
89 000.
october 66 000.
last 30 days
what was it 63 000
this is
but yeah i mean playing an hour ago or
48 hours
24 hour peak 67 000 playing an hour ago
60 000
they're staying right there though it's
literally hanging around 60k on steam
which is just bonkers
that is crazy
people are playing this game oh yeah
and see that's the difference that's why
i was about to tell you i was worried
earlier because it's like
with them trying to change anything
because it's like yo they're doing well
you know saying when things are
technically
but not happy by the hardcore so to
speak like the hardcore weed
that's why the focal minority and
they're probably like i don't care about
the vocal minority when 60 000 other
people are playing this and they should
they shouldn't i think i said last week
that like they're not making this game
for streamers right they're making it
for people but uh i i still think like
the way you do lose
is you is you
is you think that like oh
well we've always made it through so
we'll just not change anything
absolutely i can't let it stagnate i
think that they they need to be on guard
they need to be afraid of the next uh
destiny killer even though they're just
sort of standing over the graves of
anthem and division and all these other
destiny killers the borderlands
outrageous
brutally murdered
yeah
it's always the destiny it's over it's
good now this is the good name
one actually did mention though when it
comes to pvp if halo infinite pvp
actually will hurt
her now it's like i was like and that i
don't think it'll go hurt i was like
it's gonna be quiet on pvp for a little
while i think because of that oh for
sure yeah even even the uh insider
program when the insider flights
happened uh the the player base for pvp
and destiny went down i saw somebody
post that on twitter to their point the
timing is perfect right dead season now
halo comes they go underground right
they have the 30th anniversary though
you got the 30th verse you try to buff
it to get a little light yep a little
financial injection there
you take the bump from halo then come
february throw out that trailer and
whatever saboteur's doing they write
back in biz so yeah i i definitely agree
i did forget about hillary they they
they're definitely going to get hit by i
love how you're like an unofficial
ambassador for the pr team at uh bungie
now you're like giving them strategies
hey guys here's how you're going to do
it yeah
i actually i actually think they um
the reason i think they started selling
the 30th anniversary is because they
knew about what was going to happen to
the game in december because like even
if you don't play the 30th anniversary
package now you already bought it
because they marketed it to you before
it was out and you bought it thinking
yeah of course i'm gonna play it so
there's probably a group of people who
bought it and are not even gonna make
time for it but yeah i think uh if
there's any games that have like similar
players it's halo
but that only goes so far right like
they're they're not gonna lose any
players on playstation yeah there's not
gonna be a raid there's going to be you
know an 8 to 10 hour 12 hour however
long the campaign could be 20 hours for
all i know it's it does have a finite
point
and then it's the pvp life and then
unfortunately for
something like forge which i think would
really actually give it a lot of legs
we're probably six months away from that
one like that's
they said like the season after is co-op
and the season after that's forged so it
is potentially six months and i know
it's gonna have legs for you know
campaigns every year however they decide
to do all this stuff it's fine but
halo will be one of those for pvp that
is probably gonna make people
if nothing else if it hits well which
sounds like in all of the tests and
stuff that it already did
but i was like i think it's gonna get
people to push even harder for
pvp properness when it comes to destiny
because if they have ranking if they
have all these esport events in granted
it's a much more balanced game and i get
that because there's only set number of
weapons there's not roles
right and always designed that way yeah
it's like it's specific but in turn
bungie
like still is gonna have to like and
they have some plan but they're gonna
have to learn um
one random other topic i did want to ask
you guys as kind of a way to wrap this
thing up um cool guy had a really good
video that i wanted to kind of mention
basically because
it was one basically saying
and this is where i wanted to see if you
guys had an opinion about this or
otherwise
um he basically said there's really not
a whole lot of
variance when it comes to builds and
destiny did you see what i'm talking
about
and i was like and i've been asking for
this for a while and i'm sitting there
screaming like armor 3.0 and everything
else i don't know if you had a chance to
watch the video um did you
[ __ ] a little bit of it yeah like um
basically just saying the way stats are
designed the way
things are kind of designed you're
basically pushed into
almost one loadout especially for pvp
and pvp is going to be similar but do
you guys think
we have any hope in changing that or do
you even agree with what cool guy said
first i guess if you've seen it yeah
shout out to him i mean the thing with
him
he's so good he's very what i love about
cool guy is very nuanced in
specific builds and things that people
think are useless in destiny i love that
about him like he has a skill with that
and um yeah he made some good points you
know the game pushes you in specific
build directions and other things that
seem to be a certain play style they
really
they don't lean that way they the data
shows that the way bungie's designed it
doesn't lean that way and i think it is
something that they need to concern
themselves with i think that all the
stuff we've always talked about you know
i'm saying the armor 3.0 stuff the you
know skill bonuses stab bonus and stuff
like that but even with weapon play you
know from from distance and stuff like
that and they they
it's a it's a heavy hand on certain play
styles and certain aspects of play style
even with the statistical stuff that
we've always talked about like when he
talked about you know recovery and how
highly valued that's literally like the
number one stat like nothing else
compares to recovery in the entire game
right i mean you have always
you know since the flashpoint days
talked about like mobility truly making
you faster and you know
mobility still cracks me up like this
how is that how how it's like it's it's
your 80s
oh my god but yeah it's like i mean
that's where i kind of always come back
to it's like could you ever get to a
point where you had
you know six hunters who were like agile
and nimble and quicker they jumped
higher they ran faster versus six titans
who were just tanky and slow
could that would be a hilarious take
could that ever be a thing
if they can't if they don't want to do
that because they're worried because
honestly speed is like the name of the
game in destiny comp so that would like
obviously the best one so i get why they
they like under delivered on mobility
rather than over delivering because we
all saw what season of the fast warlock
was like
um yeah that's ridiculous that was that
was pretty crazy remember or they yeah
you know don't lie to me or you guys
were flying at 90 miles per hour across
the map
like a freaking pinball around the map
dude i mean i i was still killing i was
still killing you guys because you can't
aim your warlocks but uh yeah that was
wild
you know what they could do
is they could just take out the um the
ability for you to determine your um
your your spin your look sensitivity and
make that mobility there you go
oh then you're messing with controls i
can't do that
look sensitivity isn't that part of
mobility i just want to know like why
it's always been weird to me that some
settings that are sort of like your
character's movement can just be edited
in the settings you can kind of choose
how fast or slow you are but then other
ones it's like no no you need the stat
to do you can use that to move faster
it's just a weird game yeah it's just
people would be so pissed if
your look sensitivity was was tied to
your mobility stat though but yeah that
was that was just kind of a random
question it's just like builds
especially in pvp there's not like
multiple ways to really play
high mobility
is going to help
most
high recovery is going to help most and
then whether you go for supers but if
you go for like
punches and things like that he goes he
went really deep into certain exotics
like get leaned into more than others
because of specific things
and then you got like you know hunters
mobility helps to dodge warlocks
literally win the whole thing because
everybody already wants recovery so you
don't have to worry as much about the
other two so then you can lean into the
abilities more and then titans over here
get screwed on resilience because that
doesn't mean a damn thing to anybody you
just need a minimum so you can't get
like two tapped or you can use your wall
but then again you have sightings
ramparts which if you do use your wall a
lot then that thing kind of breaks like
they
it is weird that like we are at a point
where it does feel like there is a very
specific way to play
and there's not a lot of choice
like you know they want you to have rng
and stats but it's like just because the
rng in stats means you aren't getting to
the one that they know everybody wants
and it is it is kind of like there's not
multiple ways to build a character out
you take something like any other rpg
that they want and i guess that's the
thing for me is i want them i don't know
if they'll ever ever keep leaning into
the rpg mmo action rpg and i'm like you
are missing they will on they will be
pretty hard even if you even if you just
look at the light uh some class uh like
redemption
that's like that's so that's so rpg
heavy like everything they're doing
about like customizing you know your
your artifacts and your perks and all
that stuff is like is is so rpg so i
think they're i think they've shown over
the past couple years that they're
dedicated to like the rpg it's like a
a but it's like an rpg ultralight to me
it does not feel that strong
i i disagree in the game with 50
currencies i don't think you can say
it's ultralight i think you can say you
would love to take some of those out
yeah i know we all would would any of us
not do that if we had they're not like
they're arbitrary currencies they're not
typically helpful it's not like i have
six different gyms like this one gives
me strength over here it's like i have
currencies for infusion for arbitrary
like
is that you can play it fairly casually
it doesn't require you to learn all of
the systems to play it and my problem
with mmos is it's the exact opposite you
cannot play those unless you learn 40
encyclopedic systems first and so i
think they have to shoot pick and choose
their battles i think they can do an
armor
no i do not want yeah i don't i don't
think i don't think he what's that
that's fine but i i think that i think
they should sort of lean away from the
mmo like
at least the traditional mmo i like that
it's massively on multiplayer online i
just think the traditional mmo of like
making everything like a really high
barrier of entry i think they can do
armor 3.0 i think they can rework the
stat system because it already doesn't
really make a lot of sense and i think
they can do
um they can redo the light subclasses
and make things just a little more nerdy
because players get that but i think
they should try to stay away from some
of the stuff that
turns off a lot of people from like
warframe like that those systems in
warframe are wild there's just like it's
wackadoo there's so many different
systems in those games world of warcraft
is way too complicated for people that
that game is not enjoyable it's so
complicated i think a lot of people
like and there's a balance they don't
have to go into like level 100
woodcrafting for chopping down trees for
20 hours i get that but also it's like
as we've said it's like the stats
and again the way the stuff that system
doesn't make sense the stats are the
stats don't do and if that's and for me
that's why i want armor to get a revamp
is because i keep saying it's like i
have you know class items ever to delete
delete i don't care what it is there's
not a point for a class items
zero point and again if you go through
outside of farming for better stats on
an exotic if you get a decent stat roll
yeah and you master workflow i mean if
you play enough to master work like
solar arc void and stasis you have four
sets of armor and you literally don't
need more of them you could potentially
have eight if you really wanted to have
a pve and pvp set but that'd be a
the class item has devolved into
whatever the seasonal artifact yeah
that's literally it what's the height i
think the high model trying to put in
there that's it yeah it's going to cost
seven
yeah so you can't do anything else
and you know you got to keep that
particle deconstructed what was the
other one with the uh the grenade
launchers the season before i don't
remember the name but yeah
god mode grenade launchers yeah
this is what it is right now that and i
think
right i agree with trap yes i agree with
trav that it's going to be from um
they're going from a build standpoint
the sub class 3.0 like boy
that's we're going to get the builds
we're going to get a lot of build
diversity but um i'm with you on the um
the base level the stat level
i don't think they're changing that i
mean i'm hopeful i would hope they
change it i still feel a lot of those
systems are still tied into engine
that's just my gut you know a lot of
that stuff i don't know if we ever will
get that
revamp you know i'm still waiting for my
division legendary set
bonus
revamp stuff that's i think that's the
most dire thing they need and that's so
easy
it's not super nerdy and like uh like uh
confusing like some of the other rpg
systems that people propose but my thing
is i already think the mod system is
like a little it's like a little too
complicated the stat system you haven't
had to make a solar arc like you already
are limited so much on what to put in
there then you gotta have a solar piece
of armor to see this one and you can't
even see the other mod like when you're
in the solar piece it's not it's like
it's grayed out because it's arc you
can't see it you're like i got a mine
where is it but
even even then e like not only is there
not a good way to see all your mods but
there's not even a good way to see what
mods are out there and which ones you
well i mean you can look at the
collection system but you get them from
so many different sources so it's like
it's like the same problem with the
weapons like oh where did you get that
oh you had to be here four seasons ago
when uh you know osiris decided to open
a theme park and we all wore you know
you know animal costumes that season
you're like what like i i i can't do
that like you know it's just insane or
are you gonna go like
graham into this one thing and hope you
get the right role
yeah it's crazy so yeah the mod the mod
like uh discovery is bizarre to me i
think
they need a better way to do that i
agree for people who come into the game
and like they don't have a lot of these
extremely necessary
mods like protective light or the rocket
launcher one ordinance and this this
wasn't really good and it's like if you
weren't there with warbine came out and
if you weren't there like now you gotta
hope that some people don't even know
that like um what's like the 801 and and
and what you call it a banshee or are
really even selling these things right
right it's very difficult to play catch
up on destiny as a new part as a new
player and i agree like it's still all
over the place and the fact that you
know you have to now have a siva version
of the armor so you can fit deceiver
exclusive mod like it's it's it's all
yeah yeah well that's like the yeah the
stasis yeah because stasis right now you
have the now the stasis mods and the
stasis armor and then yeah whenever the
green or whatever color comes next as
you said whenever that one comes with
light fall because they were working on
it but didn't quite make it into this
expansion so now are you going to do a
fourth one
fifth one
and put that in and make us have five
sets of armor and not give me any vault
space
like that's the way we know we know what
the next two colors are going to be
right
e green and red just crisp black
one i guess you could go black yeah yeah
because it'll be it'll be like lightfall
or lightbulb
you gotta give us like they gotta give
us like a shadow element it'll be like
veil or something like that yeah yeah
yeah unfortunately black doesn't look
great on a ui for numbers and stuff like
that so what do you do there
darkness mode
[Laughter]
destiny's
after after lightfall destiny destiny's
going to live in darkness mode all the
menus are going to be black with white
text it's going to be lightful yeah
yeah that's the problem they got they
got rid of sunsetting green oh we don't
actually have yellow that's actually
true yellow would work with green yeah
get your primaries in there yeah green
and yellow because of the sports team
flawless logic there yeah green bay
packers
there we go like wrong team but that's
fine they they like seattle it'll be
green and black come on we all know
we would be cool for like the little
poison you know i mean that's what
everybody thought you have hive you have
poison you got ice and you're right
yeah it's like i think that's supposed
to have been there they just didn't get
it in this expansion for whatever reason
but we don't know that
they flat out said it so if they come
back at it now they apparently made you
know miracles happen
misdirection but generally like yeah
you're probably right the vault is like
one an issue for me because yeah i even
i'm trying to get down to where i just
keep one of each weapon
just one
and then i've got i've got too many
exotics i do need to sort through those
but like one of each weapon
and then like one of even one of each
exotic you're almost gonna have a full
vault almost oh bullcock prediction
who keeps exotics though
i do have a reason to keep exotic
weapons
because i'm like they're gonna
eventually buff something that's trash
you're taking out of collections yeah
you can yeah
like if i've infused it recently but if
i see an exotic it's like 1293 yeah
that's gone yeah i don't keep those but
if i'm like if i've got some that i've
mixed up this like i pulled a borealis
and it's like 13.29 yeah i'm gonna keep
that for the next three months because i
never know so my my bulb
addiction for your vault space
i think so sunset is coming back
man that's gonna go over really fun
that's like gas on a fire i want to
watch that
i think they're gonna i think they're
gonna sell a separate vault space app
like pokemon did for pokemon storage
there you go you want to see the first
time i like buy silver faster than i
ever have is i gotta buy vault space
we'll do it in a yeah part b it'll be
it'll be a monthly subscription you'll
pay ten dollars a month for like the the
middle package
it'll be five for it'll be five if you
want like 500 slots it'll be ten dollars
a month if you want a thousand and then
for twenty dollars a month you'll
you know be able to store however much
you know just like google drive you know
you buy like a
couple of terabytes you know two
terabytes are hundreds yeah
yeah it'll be like dropbox
yeah no it's the desktop
it'll be called the destiny content
vault i'm done the destiny
that is the model and it actually is
kind of the only one that makes sense
because uh storing items does require
server space this is my brother
okay even my brother on final fantasy 14
said he had to spend like
five maybe ten bucks and he's got so
much more storage i'm like one time do
you have any idea how many people in
this game one time would pay like five
or ten bucks to be like just double my
vault just like you want a transaction
oh yeah yeah in a heartbeat like oh
people do it 60 000 people paid 10 today
bam
i just want to see the world burn oh
when sunset comes back
this company is the same company that
vaulted your content we got to bring
hold on for that episode oh god like
when they and now if they announced this
freeze pringle this is the same company
that that
took our gear vaulted it away and now
got the audacity bro they are going to
get raped
but people ain't going to get a hawk
okay
that's one of those where i'm like i
don't know and that's the thing
that would only be if i'm buying because
i will buy my service space it's fine
with me like i as hasn't bungee said
that real like destiny casuals do not
have a problem with vault space at all
haven't they said that multiple times
that like
like basically other people have asked
what about vault space and they've been
like dude it's just you you're the only
one with this problem and
i kind of believe that because i've
never had a problem with vault space but
not because i'm a casual because i'm
just unsentimental i just get rid of
roles like right away i'm like oh i
don't care about this anymore
the reason for me has always been i know
the cycle of buff yeah they always are
my machine guns are going to come back
or this snipers are going to come back
and it's like
you keep options because what did they
say recently adrenaline junkie is going
to get a buff in december like
out of nowhere this random part that i
was like well that's kind of trash well
now they're going to make it good well
they even tell you now on twitter hold
on to those rules because they could be
good here in about a month i'm like i
don't have a place to put them
let's be real people pulling out
cartesian coordinates out of nowhere
like exactly yeah
contingency plan people that had like
bungie just it's always so it's like i'm
a victim of it i'm like yo i know this
is trash right that's a problem
yup but this roll right here is so good
on this trash archetype
that i'm just gonna keep it cause i know
they gonna buff it and when that when
they come back i'm like ah yes i'm good
i kept that very rare trash thing that
is now got here
that's how they do how they do man yeah
well as always i think that definitely
covered our bungee please for a little
while give me some damn vault space or
i'll uh yeah
yeah okay
destin i'll keep i'll be like it has
been however long since we've been
asking for vault space i'll keep it
going for destin so that way when he
comes on here he doesn't even have to
say it i got him covered
but overall i'd say this was a fun
episode
yes sir
anything else for you gentlemen to add
before we go anything that you guys are
uh
needing to get off your chest before we
wrap this episode up
that's so good this is really good i was
like
i was dreading the trousers i'm like i
was getting exhausted i was like this is
really fun
like i was like i really enjoyed this
one we kind of we kind of glossed over
the trials too we didn't even really
spend much time on it we've we've all
just we're so sick of talking about the
trials
yeah it was fun i'm glad you you had the
other talking points to you because it
was so fun to talk about those other
things and just what we want but uh yeah
dope episode as always nice
well gentlemen as we wrap this thing up
we'll start with you travis where
where's the next thing people can find
from you or if you can you probably
can't even give an embargo date if
you're working on anything but watch ign
look for this name of travis northup and
just search that daily at about four
o'clock in the afternoon type in travis
north up ign every single day
and see
yeah
yeah uh
i've got a review live right now uh
writer's republic which i liked a lot
spoiler alert i gave it an 8 out of 10.
that means it's great um i really
enjoyed it
i've got another preview i'm working on
and i'm also working on the wiki for
forza 5. uh i'm going to be finding
every single
uh xp board and fast travel station in
that game so i'm
this is actually my first wiki
so uh i have no idea if if i'm gonna be
qualified or good at it but i do love
the forza game so i should be able to
find them all right how hard could it be
he said is his last words
final last phrase
you can find me uh every sunday morning
at 8 00 am uh pacific uh on a show
called bitcast we compete directly with
the iron lords podcast and we talk trash
on them the entire time
actually that's that's most of our
podcast is us just like talking about
how there are amateurs and all that
stuff
i do the show with a guy named ames an
industry veteran a legend and uh the
live action fred flintstone a guy named
dan um which is very fun um
yeah so uh you can find me in those
places also follow me on twitter i'm at
ty guy travis and if you don't follow me
uh that's probably a good choice
selling yourself so well as always we
appreciate it travis cog what do you got
any awesome guests come in any episodes
or videos they should look up on ilp
what do you got yeah check out my mad
attic man he did his first like kind of
major review
for a video review from forza horizon 5.
very honored to get that on the channel
it was great it's hilarious the forza
haters perspective i mean the driving
game haters perspective of forza horizon
5. so it was really cool definitely
picked your audience well on that one
yeah yeah like you knew what he was
doing salute to him but he was able to
get the code and knock that out so check
that out um iop this week don't guess
we're just gonna keep it regular you
know we may have some surprise popping
just you know it's all week for you
light work man i need it i need it bro
too many too many podcasts and sometimes
that's why i said i really
enjoyed this show because i was like
sometimes you just gotta be with the fam
you know what i mean just with the fear
like like how we doing today
travis if you've ever needed to roast
somebody i need you to start stocking up
for one of our guests because when mooch
finally comes on this show i need you to
light up light him oh
i can't wait
yeah because because he's been bumped a
couple times trying to get trying to get
ready to be on the show and be like dude
ready
it has been it has been way too long
since i've made somebody cry so i'm very
excited we don't want to quite do that
to our guests oh no we will
he said
check out the friday duke this week some
fun conversations with mr maddie please
talking about the sega partnerships
checking all that good stuff out what's
going on in the xbox world and um last
word podcast like and subscribe like and
subscribe hit the notification bell
will you kill your friends how are your
friends you know
all 50 of you still in here at the end
man it's a little bit a lot of fun chat
was absolutely hilarious as always trav
the homie the homie tons of fun as
always yeah man fun week it was just i
needed a week like this just to kind of
decompress and just talk about gaming
without always prepping for big guests
all the time so but we're still happy
e what's going on with you uh you gotta
tag me wait you gotta i gotta put you up
please tag me when you tweet your video
sir tag me in your videos so we can get
that promotion going on brother fair
enough fair enough
so talk more about eldon ring i feel
like you don't talk enough about that
game yes yes oh my god like i just want
to break down that entire 15 minutes
frame by frame but that would be way too
long
i want to pick i want a video of you of
you talking about alden ring and i want
you to be shirtless and just covered in
sweat the whole time yeah
because honestly that would because i
feel like that's your energy right like
hurtless and covered in sweat what did i
just get done
i was outside like rowing in the texas
heat and then i just walked in to record
a video go yeah not not physical sweat i
want it to be like that mental sweat you
know like with the yarn board behind you
and you've got like you're like you're
like going through the trailer and you
look like you haven't slept in like
three days and you got no shirt on for
some reason maybe blood i don't know
we are past halloween yeah that's for
the only fans dramatic got it right
that's on the only fans
that's where that goes i love how he
like travis always
i live in like one of the biggest cities
in like the states and uh
i'm just saying do you want views or not
e do you want views or not
what are you willing to do it's for the
content it's for the content right not
only fans would be
he's like hey you paying some bills
we're gonna make it work
right that's right get out there baby
get out get out go work work that corner
work it work it out
hilarious i digress actually i think we
digressed but i digress
travis digressed uh no i'm trying to
decide if i'm going to go game pass or
premium for forza if i wait like four
days that might give me time to go for
lost ark actually so if i put some time
into the lost ark beta
focus on that then i can just wait like
four days and play
sports on game pass which will probably
suffice what i'm going for if you do can
we all three of us do a forza
cross play session
i would love to test that out pc
you know what i'm saying console all
together absolutely let's try that you
know all of us you know for the most
part that'll be kind of fun you know
what's that let's try forza session yes
uh
shout out to dr foo by the way with the
raid if you guys are coming over thank
you i didn't even know youtube raids but
if you said go over to another channel
in somebody's life that's impressive by
the way if you manage to youtube raid
no i think he just manually told people
to go here or put a link in his chat so
that's that's some dedication right
there so thank you it seems like it
seems like they joined right when we
started talking about the shirtless raid
so i thought that was all relationships
we were literally talking about like
destiny for like an hour and a half
other games before that you guys get
here in the five minutes when this place
goes to hell
yeah
this is
yeah i'm in a racing helmet and no shirt
the helmet stayed on ebontis edition
yeah there you go you gotta yeah you
gotta keep the helmet on gotta be you
gotta be safe
in these bunnies
uh no yeah checking out lost ark
obviously got zur tomorrow not really
doing a whole bunch in the world of
trials because it's not there and then
forza but yeah still just like working
through guides gonna work on my
solo prophecy guide work back on a
pressage guide just kind of some of
those for guides of stuff that people
can do when they're coming in and just
guides for like newer people
or people who are still going to be
tripping into this game every day
because there's 60 000 people playing it
and most of them
are not on the level that we are on so
trying to help out the ones that i can
so that's mostly what i'm doing but if
you guys enjoy the show if you got this
far um for one if you enjoy the show go
find us on audio platforms like spotify
itunes anything like that leave us a
review over there also here on the
channel drop the likes you know
subscribe to all of these awesome
gentlemen follow them on twitter go read
the log net articles go read the ign
articles hit f5 6 000 times get those
numbers up
uh but for all of you guys out there
this has been a very fun episode i want
to thank my host as always travis cogg
you guys are fantastic and this was just
a fun one a chat kind of some grievances
letting you know air in the dirty
laundry a little bit right now just kind
of getting everything out there
it is one of those weeks it's just going
to kind of be that way and the
distractions are gonna start coming
so i think as we wrap up this episode
you guys are all fantastic thank you for
the raid by the way sorry you caught us
at the weirdest moment possible thank
you travis or did you
i've got a patreon and then the only
fans that's the one you got to dig deep
to fight right yeah only the only thing
you're missing is you got to start
making conspiracy videos just like uh
the more whack that's like the other
thing on youtube that's real hot right
now is if you can uh you can just make
some uh make some unsubstantiated claims
that'd be great
i'll probably stay out of that craziness
that seems
weird that that probably leads to a
weird rabbit hole
well fine all right suit yourself i'm
just trying to market you bro oh that's
good that's good
uh well thank you all very much we're
gonna wrap this one up here so episode
number 172 for november 4. thank you all
for the support and love out there you
guys are amazing we will see you soon
and for this episode it has been
the last word